I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hello. Lady, we have a great day today. We have another re-visited deep dive episode of Office, ladies. Yes. Today we are going to go back over the second half of season three. We're going to get to your questions, your comments about all the things we missed. We're doing everything from back from vacation to the job. Yeah, we are. And
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎。大家好。大家好。女郎们，我们今天过得真棒。我们有一集《办公室》女郎的重访深度剖析节目。是的。今天我们要回顾第三季的后半部分。我们将解答你们的问题，以及你们对我们所有遗漏之处的评论。我们将从度假归来到求职，无所不包。是的，我们会的。还有
I want you to know I'm holding what looks like a small phone book in my hand because we went through so many questions and comments. And Jen and I both jotted a ton down and we're excited to talk to you guys today. Yeah, it's like 19, 20 pages, I think. Yes, it is. But first we have some exciting news. We are going to start this off with a deep dive with our awesome cinematographer and director, Randall Einhorn. Randall was the cinematographer for 64 episodes. And he directed the accountants, webisodes, as well as 15 episodes of The Office. This man knows this show inside and out. We are so excited to talk to him. Guys, Randall was one of our original visionaries for the show. He really helped shape the world,
我想让你们知道，我手里拿着一本看起来像小型电话簿的东西，因为我们收到了太多的问题和评论。珍娜和我俩都记下了大量内容，我们很高兴今天能和大家聊聊。是的，大概有19、20页吧，我想。是的，确实如此。但首先我们有一些激动人心的消息。我们将以与我们出色的摄影指导兼导演兰德尔·艾因霍恩的深度剖析访谈来开启本期节目。兰德尔曾担任64集的摄影指导。他执导了网络剧《会计师》，以及15集《办公室》。这个人对这部剧了如指掌。我们非常高兴能与他交谈。伙计们，兰德尔是本剧最初的远见者之一。他真的塑造了这个世界，
the mockumentary style. He has also been amazing. I've been reaching out to him. You've been reaching out to him, Angela. You might remember he gave us all of the amazing details about Michael's car going into the lake. So we are really excited to get this deep dive interview with him for the pod. So you guys, when we all got on the zoom with Randall, we were so excited to see each other. It was the first time the three of us, I mean, Jenna, I don't even know the last time the three of us were together. So we got super excited. We did all of our hellos and forgot to hit record. Yes. Sam was like, guys, are you recording? And I was like, Oh, crap. Yeah. So when you hear this interview, we're going to jump right
这种伪纪录片风格。他一直都太棒了。我一直在联系他。你也在联系他，安吉拉。大家可能还记得，他向我们透露了迈克尔的车冲进湖里的所有精彩细节。所以我们非常高兴能在播客中对他进行深度访谈。所以大家，当我们所有人通过Zoom与兰德尔连线时，我们都太兴奋了能见到彼此。这是我们三个人——我是说，珍娜，我都不知道我们三个人最后一次聚在一起是什么时候。所以我们超级兴奋。我们打完了招呼，却忘记按录制了。是的。山姆当时说：“伙计们，你们在录制吗？”然后我说：“噢，糟了。”是的。所以当你听到这段访谈时，我们会直接切入
in because we talked for 20 minutes without hitting record. Yeah. Oh, Sam, Sam, Sam. Every week you're like, and should you hit record every week? Sam, can you play that interview? Randall, we always start by asking people basically the same question, which is how did you come to be on the office? I was doing a reality TV show, kind of an extreme sports thing where I had to ski with Sean White and some other legendary skier and I had to keep up with these guys skiing and film these extreme skiers and Jackson Hole. It was kind of an extreme sports thing for Ben Silverman. And then at that time, apparently decided that's the guy. Wait, when he, when he decided this, were you flying down a mountain holding a
因为我们聊了20分钟却没有按录制。是的。哦，山姆，山姆，山姆。每周你都会说：“你们按录制了吗？”山姆，你能播放那段访谈吗？兰德尔，我们通常以问大家基本相同的问题开始，那就是你是怎么来到《办公室》的？我当时在做一档真人秀节目，有点像极限运动节目，我必须和肖恩·怀特以及其他一些传奇滑雪者一起滑雪，我必须跟上这些滑雪者的速度，并在杰克逊霍尔拍摄这些极限滑雪者。这有点像是为本·西尔弗曼制作的极限运动节目。然后在那时，显然他决定那就是这个人。等等，当他、当他决定这一点时，你正抓着相机飞驰在山坡上吗？对。我觉得那也是这个人。对，但我觉得对任何事来说他都是那个人。但是，从一个在滑雪板上拍摄的家伙，跳跃到拍摄一个安静、封闭的办公小隔间，这确实是一个奇特的转变。是的。我从户外冒险家变成了办公室小隔间男。本说服格雷格那个人就是他。我记得格雷格和我在一家星巴克碰面，格雷格说：“就在圣莫尼卡的星巴克见吧。”我刚到洛杉矶，我去了洛杉矶50家星巴克中的一家，我终于联系上了格雷格，我迟到了大约一个小时，而格雷格还在那儿等着我，我们进行了一次非常棒的会面，感觉棒极了，这就是我和格雷格真正一拍即合的地方。你把
camera? Yeah. I would say that's the guy too. Yeah, but I would say that's the guy for anything. But I, it is a curious jump to go from guy filming on skis to filming a quiet contained office cubicle. Yes. I went from outdoor adventure guy to the office guy. Ben convinced Greg that that's the guy. I remember Greg and I met this at a Starbucks and Greg said, just meet me at the Starbucks on Santa Monica. I was new to Los Angeles and I went to one of the 50s Starbucks in Los Angeles and I finally got in touch with Greg and I showed up like an hour late and Greg is still sitting there just waiting for me and we had a fantastic meeting and it was wonderful and that's where Greg and I really hit it off. Did you bring
马特·索恩带进这个项目了吗？他是B组摄影机操作员。是的。你们以前合作过吗？对，你们俩以前就认识，对吧？马特和我通过户外冒险界认识，也通过《幸存者》和《生态挑战》认识，我们在那种真实风格、你知道的纪录片风格中一起拍摄过场景，当你以这种真实风格一起拍摄场景时，你真的能很快弄清楚谁在照顾你，谁在配合你做你正在做的事，以及那种真实的舞蹈。马特和我配合得非常好。我记得有几次我们一起拍摄，他会说，哦，他明白我在做什么，我也明白他在做什么，我们可以通过——你知道的，没有藏在摄像机后面的那只眼睛看着对方并进行交流，我只是觉得马特是我进行这种舞蹈的最佳人选。兰德尔，在经历了你们拍摄过的一切之后，待在这个装有荧光灯的办公隔间仓库办公空间里，你难道不觉得太无聊了吗？不。我们拍过。我们总是拍摄那些我们只需做出反应的东西。这就是真实电影。你只是在反应。你只是在收集周围发生的事情，能够逆向工程并在实际上让人觉得你只是在捕捉它，这真的很酷。我以前从未真正从事过叙事类的工作。我一直都在做真人秀和纪录片，把剧本化的东西拍得像纪录片一样，这真的很酷，
Matt Sohn into the picture? He was the B camera operator. Yes. Had you worked together before? Yeah, you guys knew each other, right? Matt and I knew each other from the outdoor adventure world and also from survivor and eco challenge and we filmed scenes together and when you're filming a scene together in kind of this Verite style, you know, documentary style, you really ascertain really quickly who's looking out for you and who's doing the compliment of what you're doing and that Verite dance. Matt and I did really, really well. I remember just a couple of times that we've shot together and he's like, oh, he gets what I'm doing and I get what he's doing and we can look at each other out of the, you know, out of
因为这需要另一层技巧。通常情况下，你只是坐在那儿，拍摄发生的现实，你只是坐在卡车上。如果我们一直坐在摇臂或三脚架上，而且我知道每个人要说什么，我只是在平移。是的，我会觉得无聊。但能够做出反应，你知道的，扮演一个角色。你确实是。你是一个角色。你是。谢谢。你知道吗，不过我总是想到你们。我是说，珍娜和我谈过这个，因为我们知道你和马特经历过的一些冒险。你在片场跟我们分享过。当我们遇到诸如舞台上点燃蜡烛的情况时，我们总是会咯咯笑，而我们的助理导演凯利·坎特利会说：“安全会议。我们要点一支蜡烛。”而珍娜和我深知，你曾把摄像机绑在身上，去闯婆罗洲河流里的小艇什么的，兰德尔却说：“好吧，点燃的蜡烛。明白了。”是的。关于蜡烛的安全会议相当……它们显然还是会让我至今记忆犹新。但我认为这一切都是以安全的名义完成的，因为安全永不放假。所以没错。是的。好吧，兰德尔，你和格雷格关于剧集的视觉风格或保持纪录片风格进行过哪些早期的讨论？你们当时是否有某种总体规划？你们将如何拍摄
the eye that's not behind the camera and communicate and I just felt Matt was the best person for me to do that dance with. Randall, were you so bored to be inside of this cubicle warehouse office space with these fluorescent lights after all you guys had shot? No, we had shot. We had always shot things that we just reacted to. That's what Cinema Verite is. You're just reacting. You're just gleaning what's happening around you and it was really cool to kind of reverse engineer that and actually have to make it look like you were just getting it. I never really worked in narrative stuff before. I'd always done, you know, reality and documentaries and it was really cool to make scripted stuff look like a documentary
以及它看起来会是什么样？非常有。我看过原版的《办公室》，也就是英国版。当格雷格和我见面时，我向他提出了这个想法。我说这有点像素热狗。所以它就像是用坏食物包裹的好食物。这有点像你在它外面刷上一层虚假的清漆，这样人们就会倾向于靠近它。我们在像《幸存者》这样的节目以及我做过的所有真人秀和纪录片中总是做的一件事是，当对话很亲密时，你会从它退后。你不会像普通电视那样凑上去。你会退后，退后，再退后，因为这会让观众觉得他们正在窥探某种他们不一定应该窥探的东西。
because it took another layer of finesse. You know, normally you're just sitting there and you're filming what happens and you're just sitting there on the truck. Had we been sitting there on dollies or on a tripod and I'm just, know what everybody's going to say and I'm just doing pans. Yeah, I would have been bored. But to be able to react and you know, and play a character. You were. You were a character. You were. Thank you. Yeah. You know what though, I did always think of you guys. I mean, Jenna and I have talked about this because we knew like some of the adventures you and Matt had had. You had shared with us on set. We always sort of chuckled when we would have a situation like a lit
所以他们觉得他们加入了这个笑话。他们觉得融入了当时的时刻。我认为这增加了一种非常美好的亲密感。作为一名演员，兰德尔，我喜欢你为了那些亲密时刻将摄像机拿开的做法，因为作为演员最困难的事情之一就是屏蔽掉距离你仅几英寸的摄像机。这非常具有解放感。这真的是我最喜欢的体验之一，那些时刻感觉是多么的私密，因为你们离得更远。是的。是的。是的。自从《办公室》之后，我现在也参与过一些节目。我拍过这样一个场景，摄像机离得太近了，以至于当另一个演员停顿不说话时，我只能听到机械噪音，因为摄像机就是那么近。然后你试图说，好吧，我
candle on stage and Kelly Cantley, our AD would be like safety meeting. We're going to lie to candle. And like Jenna and I knowing that you had a camera strapped to you like going down like some like boat in a river and Borneo like Randall's like, okay, lit candle. Got it. Yeah. Yeah. Safety meetings over a candle are quite, they're clearly something that still gets me to this day. But I think it's all done in under the name of safety because safety never takes a holiday. So that's right. Yeah. Well, Randall, what were some of the early conversations you had with Greg about the look of the show or preserving the documentary style? Did you guys have sort of a game plan? How you were going to shoot
听不到那个机械噪音。我和这个人同处此时此地。是的。我觉得把片场完全交给演员总是值得称道的。作为现在的导演，这也是我总是尽量退后并顺其自然的事。它不应该成为我的环境。它应该成为演员的环境。这是我在《办公室》里从一些伟大的导演那里绝对学到的东西。好吧，作为一名演员，我喜欢这样。是的，我们喜欢。兰德尔，当你担任摄影指导时，你能跟我们讲讲你是如何与导演一起筹备一个场景的吗，比如值班室里的一个标准场景，而你必须捕捉一堆反应？你是如何筹备的？对于《办公室》，我们基本上
and what it was going to look like? Very much so. I saw the original office, you know, the British version. And when Greg and I met, I pitched him this idea. I said it's kind of like a tofu hot dog. So it's like good food that's wrapped like bad food. And it's kind of you're putting this fake veneer on it so that people kind of lean in. And the one thing that we always did on shows like Survivor and all reality that I ever did in documentaries is when a conversation is intimate, you back away from it. You don't go to it like normal TV. You back away and you back away and you back away because that makes the viewer think that they're privy to something that they shouldn't necessarily be privy to.
倾向于排练一个场景，演员们会做演员们会做的事。然后我和马特就会像这样站在那里。这是我们的摄像机。然后我和马特会看着对方，心想：好吧，我搞定这个了。我拍珍娜。太棒了。你拍吉姆。太棒了。在珍娜的台词之后，我要摇镜头到吉姆。所以我要把他们这样连接起来。然后马特会蹲下。我会拍到那个。然后我会重新站起来，我们就会——我们俩基本上就站在那里。如果你看看像《幸存者》这样的节目，比如说，两个人说话，你有所谓的“干净镜头过肩”，你并不一定需要让那个人的画面保持干净，你试图连接他们。这是我们
So they feel in on the joke. They feel in on the moment. And I think it adds a level of intimacy that is really nice. As an actor, Randall, I loved how you would back that camera off for those intimate moments, because one of the hard things as an actor is blocking out the camera that is inches away from you. And it was very freeing. It was one of my favorite experiences really is how private those moments really felt because you guys were further away. Yeah. Yes. Yes. I've been on shows now since the office. I did this scene and the camera was so close that when the other actor paused and talking, I could just hear because the camera was that close. And you're trying to like say, okay, I'm
一直努力在做的事情，通过将两个角色的形象都放在我们的取景框中来展现这种人际联系。所以我和马特必须把对方框在画面之外。有时候这意味着你需要后退一点，并在镜头上拉得更长一点。这样你看不到马特的肩膀、马特的膝盖或什么的。所以是的，我们就会坐在那里，我们会对它做出反应。然后我和马特就会跳这样一支舞，来弄清楚我们的拍摄范围是什么。我记得哈罗德·雷米斯来执导。那是——那是超级酷的时刻。哈罗德来了。我的意思是，他多筹备了一个星期，因为他太兴奋能做这个节目了，我记得每个人——史蒂夫欣喜若狂。
not hearing that mechanical noise. I'm in the moment with this other person. Yeah. I think there's something always to be said for just giving the set to actors. It's something I as a director now, I always try to back away and just let it be. It shouldn't be my environment. It should be the actor's environment. That's something I absolutely learned on the office from some of the great directors. Well, as an actor, I love it. Yeah, we do. Randall, can you tell us a little bit about how you would prep a scene with a director when you were in the role of cinematographer, like a standard scene in the bullpen, and you're having to cover a bunch of reactions? How would you prep that? For the office, we would basically
我们当时在史蒂夫的办公室里拍摄一个场景。他就在那里。但我的意思是，哈罗德真的、真的做了充分的筹备，他有所有那些计划，就像我精心绘制的那样。我记得我们排练了第一个场景。然后我和马特就站在那里，做了这个那个，讨论了一番。我看着他，他看着我，我们弄清楚了谁来拍什么。哈罗德走过来，他说：“我应该扔掉这个，对吧？”我说：“不，哈罗德，这真的——能跟你合作真是太荣幸了。而且，是的，是的，别逗我了孩子，我应该扔掉这个计划，对吧？你们刚才做的比这个好多了。”我说：“嗯，这是一个很棒的路线图，
just tend to rehearse a scene and the actors would do what the actors would do. And Matt and I would just stand there like this. And this is our camera. And Matt and I would be looking at each other like, okay, I got this. I got Jenna. Great. You've got Jim. Great. I'm going to do a swing to Jim after Jenna's line. So I'm going to connect them like that. And Matt would duck. And I would get that. And then I'd come back up and we would we would just kind of both stand there. And if you look at shows like I'm like survivor, let's say, where you have two people talking and you have the what we call dirty overs, you don't have the person necessarily clean, you try to connect them. And that was something
哈罗德。”然后，你知道的，我们又拍了一个场景，我记得我看着他，看着他，他引起了我的注意。他直接把他的拍摄计划扔进了帕姆的垃圾桶里。我清楚地记得我们当时在哪儿。是的。哈罗德·雷米斯把他的拍摄计划扔进了帕姆的垃圾桶，因为他觉得你们的表现太棒了。太棒了，兰德尔。那对——对我和我来说，我会觉得：“有人去把那些从垃圾桶里拿出来。我要留着它们。”是的。是的。好吧，我必须说，我很好奇你对那个问题的回答会是什么，因为我的记忆是，基本上都是你和马特在我们的排练期间弄清楚镜头，而
that we always tried to do is to show that human connection by placing both characters in both of our frames. So Matt and I would have to just frame each other out. And sometimes that means you need to back up and get a little bit longer on the lens. So you see, you don't see Matt's shoulder or Matt's knee or whatever. So yeah, we would just sit there and we would react to it. And Matt and I would just do this to do this dance where we would figure out what what our coverage was. And I remember Harold Ramis directing. And it was it was a coolest moment. His Harold came in. I mean, he prepped like an extra week, because he was so excited about doing the show, which I just everybody I remember Steve was giddy.
导演们则更专注于演员的表演，给我们意见，确保我们抛出的笑梗都奏效，确保编剧们把他们的备用笑梗加进去。实际上，大家有着巨大的信任，相信你们知道如何拍摄这部剧。导演们在绝大多数情况下并没有以任何方式对你们进行微观管理。我不记得有人对我说过“在这句台词上切到他”或者“漏掉这句台词”。情况总是这样，你知道的，当我——当我进行交谈时，这也是我至今仍在做的事情，当我跟摄像机说话时，我对摄像机操作员说话就像我对演员说话一样。我会说：“你认为这个，但你也怀疑她可能会那样做。”而这赋予了
He we were in this in Steve's office and doing a scene. He was right there. But I mean, Harold really, really prepped and he had all those plans like I had just meticulously drawn out. And I remember we rehearsed the first scene. And Matt and I just kind of stood there and did this and that and talked it through. And I looked at him and he looked at me and we figured out who was going to get what. And Harold came up, he says, I should just get rid of this, right? I'm like, no, Harold, it's really, it's such an honor to be working with you. And yeah, yeah, don't shit me, kid, I should get rid of this plan. Right. This is what you did was way better. I'm like, well, that's a, it's a great roadmap,
摄像机一点点观点，对于《办公室》来说，这是至关重要的，对于其他节目来说，我也觉得很有趣，因为你信任摄像机操作员的直觉，你为他们提供了为场景增添技巧的基础，我认为这总是非常有趣的。太美妙了。我喜欢那样。好吧，你知道吗，兰德尔，你们非常擅长的另一件事就是捕捉那些没有按剧本写下来的时刻。我认为我们拍摄的方式增加了一层真实感，即兴创作的时刻也是如此。无论我们是否使用即兴创作的时刻，它仍然把每个人都带入到
Harold. And, and then, you know, we did one more scene and I remember watching him looking at him and he got my attention. He just shocked his plans and Pam's trash bin. I remember exactly where we were. Yeah. Harold Ramis threw his shot plans into Pam's trash bin because he thought you nailed it. That, that's great, Randall. That is, that would, for me, I'd be like, someone go get those out of the trash. I'm saving those. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I have to say, I was really curious what your answer was going to be to that question because my memory is that for the most part, it was you and Matt figuring out the shots during our rehearsal and the
“这一切正在发生”的空间里。这是一件真实的事情。这有一种即兴感。这不是排练好的东西。这是正在我们面前和我们周围发生的事情。你们所有人能成为其中的一部分真是太棒了。看到角色从不出戏，真是太神奇了。凯文一直在做凯文，安吉拉一直在做安吉拉。在我看来，加入这些时刻让它感觉像是一个有生命的东西，并且以一种真正有意义且重大的方式让它感觉真实且有机，从而影响了整体的结果。太富有诗意了。这是我听过的关于片场即兴创作的最好的回答。
directors were more focused on just actor performance, giving us notes, making sure we landed the jokes, making sure that the writers got their alternate jokes in. And really there was this huge trust that you guys knew how to shoot the show. The directors didn't, for the most part, like micromanage you in any way. I don't recall anybody ever telling me get to him on this line or miss this line. It was always, and you know, when I, when I went, and it's, it's something I still do when I'm talking to cameras, I talk to a camera operator like I'm talking to an actor. I will say you think this, but you also suspect that she might do that. And that kind of gives
好吧，兰德尔，我知道我们大部分时间都把你关在荧光灯下的那个办公室里，但偶尔我们也会把你塞进汽车后座，或者把你放在船上。感觉怎么样？那些拍摄日对你来说是怎样的？在许多尴尬的地方拍摄，爱因斯坦说过，困难之中蕴藏着机遇。事情越艰难，效果就越好。就像我刚刚重看了车里开往湖边的那个场景。整个过程中我只是在做出反应。我记得那些，你知道的，在所有事情发生的过程中，水涌进来，我被挤在后座上，尽管很困难。当GPS说话时，我将镜头平移到GPS上，
the camera a little bit of a point of view, which for the office is paramount for other shows I think is also interesting because you're trusting the intuition of the camera operator and you're giving them the basis to add some finesse to a scene, which I think is always really interesting. That's beautiful. I love that. Well, you know, Randall, one of the things you guys were also so great at was catching these moments that weren't scripted. I think that the way we filmed it added a level of authenticity as did the improvisational moments. And whether we'd use improvisational moments or not, it still put everybody in
因为它是场景中的一个角色。所以我认为这些机会以一种非常、非常有趣的方式增添了另一个元素。但就像迈克尔的西百灵一样，他对此感到非常骄傲，那是一辆双门轿跑车。它是一辆两门车。所以后座，虽然它是一辆四座车或五座车，但对两座外加一个摄影师来说并不是非常舒服，因为我记得摄像机比后窗还要高，因为那是一辆太酷的车了，迈克尔，后窗的坡度太大了，以至于我的摄像机总是会撞到后窗。那里还有一个变速箱穿过的突起，你的腿真的无处可放。所以你只能把自己
that space of this is happening. This is a real thing. There's an immediacy to this. It's not a rehearsed thing. It's something that is happening in front of us and around us. And for you all to be part of that was awesome. It was amazing to see, you know, characters never drop character. They just kept Kevin, kept being Kevin and Angela kept being Angela. And adding those moments in to me made it feel like a living thing and made it feel real and organic in a really meaningful and significant way that affected the overall outcome. That is so poetic. That is the best answer I have ever heard about improv on a set.
系成一个结，并希望通过这种不适找到一些机会。你知道的，我晕车。我真的很晕车。什么？是的。每次我从车里出来时。你到底是怎么工作的？是的。哦，天哪，你真的很晕车？继续。兰德尔，我完全不知道，因为很多次我们在车里拍摄时，我们只是兜圈子。我们绕着圈子开，仅仅是绕圈子我就开始感到恶心了。是的更不用说只用一只眼了。是的。不，我真的很晕车。我记得每次克里斯、克里斯和埃德都在帮我把沉重的摄像机搬出来，帮我出来。他们会问：“你怎么样？你没事吧？你还好吗？”我说：“挺好，挺好。”现在我们知道了，
Well, Randall, I know that we kept you in that office under the fluorescent light most of the time, but occasionally we did cram you into the backseat of a car or we put you on a boat. What was it like? What were those shoot days for you like? A shot note in a lot of awkward places, Einstein said, in the midst of difficulty lies opportunity. And the harder it got, the better it got. Like I just rewatched that scene in the car where we're driving to the lake. And the whole time I was just reacting to it. And I remember those, you know, in the midst of everything happening as difficult as it was with the water coming in and me cramped in the backseat. When the GPS spoke, I panned to the GPS because
这要持续好几个小时，但我们有太多的驾驶场景了，兰德尔。我从来不知道这一点。是的。哦，天哪。是的。我当时在后面脸色有点发绿。我只是出很多汗。好吧，谢谢你，因为这确实产生了一些非常惊人的成果。那太有趣了。我知道我们正在讨论像高难度的摄像机位置之类的东西，但是兰德尔，你必须跟每个人分享一下。你给我们引进了“便便滑板车”（Pootie Scooty）。“便便滑板车”。但是是你发明的吗？那是戴尔为你制作的吗？戴尔为我们制作的。我们当时想：我希望能坐在演员的水平高度在办公室里滑行并移动，你知道的，不是坐在摇臂上。我们只是
it was a character in the scene. So those opportunities, I think, add another element in a really, really interesting way. But like Michael's Sebring, which he was so proud of, it was a coupe. It was a two door. So the backseat, although it's a four-seater car or five-seater car, it wasn't a two-seater plus a cameraman very comfortably because I remember the camera came up higher than the back window because it was such a cool car, Michael, that the back window had such a slope to it that my camera would always hit the back of the window. And there was a hump there where the transmission went through and there's really kind of no place for your legs to go. So you just kind of tie
希望快速且敏捷，同时也为了让我能对此做出反应，而不是去跟一个机械师沟通说我需要前后移动，因为我要向左摇镜头。我们永远做不到这一点。所以戴尔制作了那些。那太棒了。那个东西运作得非常、非常棒。太有趣了。它就像一个滚动的箱子。然后他们最终在它顶部给你弄了一个小垫子，对吧？垫子。那真是些好日子。是的，那真是些好日子。而且你可以转圈。它有点像凳子，但对你来说比凳子好一点，因为我觉得它是方的。是的。你离开《办公室》时把“便便滑板车”带走了吗？我没有。我没有。你没有。没有。
yourself in a knot and hopefully find some opportunity by that discomfort. You know, I get, I get carsick. I get really carsick. What? Yeah. Every time I got out of a car. How in the world do you do your job? Yeah. Oh my God, you get really carsick? Go on. Randall, I had no idea because so many times when we filmed in cars, we just looped. We did a circle and I would get nauseous just doing the circle. Yeah. Let alone only with one eye. Yeah. No, I get really carsick. And I remember every time Chris, Chris and Ed were helping me get the heavy camera out and helping me come out. They're like, how are you doing? You all right? You okay? I'm like, yeah, real good. And now we know it
从那以后，我让人为我制作了其他的“便便滑板车”，但就是不一样了。哦，是的。是的。好吧，我觉得我想告诉我们的观众的一件事是，摄影指导同时还要操作摄像机是多么的罕见。听起来兰德尔你为了把摄像机一直握在手里做了多么艰苦的斗争。你不想把它放在三脚架上。你不想把它放在摇臂上。你是操作员。在我参与过其他项目中，通常真的是摄影指导在指导摄像机操作员，他们不会把手放在摄像机上太多。这就像是一件非常酷的事情。是的。我认为总有一种脱节的元素，因为在传统的
lasts a couple hours, but we had so many, we had so many driving scenes, Randall. I never knew this. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Yeah. I was getting a little green at times back there. I was just kind of sweating a lot. Well, thank you because it really did produce some amazing, amazing things. That was fun. I know we're sort of talking about like difficult camera positions and stuff, but Randall, you have to share with everybody. You introduced us to the Pootie Scooty. The Pootie Scooty. But did you invent that? Was that something Dale made for you? Dale made it for us. We were like, I would love to be able to scoot around the office at actor level and move, you know, not like on a dolly. And we just
节目中，通常有八到十个人专门负责两台摄像机。而在我们的节目中，我们的摄像机部门只有四个人。就是我和马特、克里斯和埃德。我和马特自己调整焦距，我们自己调整光圈。我会为摄像机设置外观，你知道的，我会对摄像机进行编程，设定我们希望它们看起来的样子以及我们希望它们如何匹配。然后剩下的事情都在后期制作中解决，但我和马特认为自己调整焦距和光圈非常重要。我也认为，当操作员是场景的一部分并且也在聆听场景时，这又达到了一种亲密感。而这是
wanted to be quick and nimble and also so that I can react to it as opposed to communicating to a grip that I need to move back and forth because I'm going to pan to the left. We never would have gotten there. So Dale built those. And that was great. That thing worked really, really well. It was so fun. It was like a rolling box. And then they eventually got you a little cushion on top of it. Right? Cushion. Those were the days. Yeah, those were the days. And you could spin around. It was like kind of like a stool, but a little better than a stool for you because I think it was like square. Yeah. Did you take the Pootie Scooty with you when you left the office? I didn't. I didn't. You didn't. No.
在很多节目中都不会发生的事情，很多节目中，摄影指导根本不听台词。我想知道你怎么知道该做什么？是的。因为在拍摄纪录片时，我不知道该拍什么，直到我的收音师把吊杆伸出来说：“这是一段相关的对话。你该拍这个白痴。别拍那个。”所以我仍然——嘿，当我操作时，我戴着耳机。所以我能听到正在发生的事情，这样我可以微调我正在做的事情。现在兰德尔，有时候在我们的片场，事情会变得有点肢体冲突。谁撞到你了？你跟谁相撞得最多？你知道的，我想我说过，我在拍火灾那一集时把自己摔到了地板上。我记得我是倒退着穿过厨房，
And since and since then I've had other Pooties Scooties built for me and there just weren't the same. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Well, I feel like something I want to tell our audience is how incredibly rare it is for a cinematographer to also operate the camera. And it sounds like Randall, you fought so hard to always keep that camera in your hands. You did not want to put it on sticks. You did not want to put it on a dolly. You were the operator. And in other projects I've done, it really is usually a cinematographer directing a camera operator and they don't put their hands on the camera so much. It was like this really cool thing. Yeah. I think there's always an element of disconnect because on traditional
然后我摔倒了，我想我撞到了地面，但我不是很确定。但我是一个200磅重的人，摄像机有38磅重。我记得克里斯·沃克曼，他是一个非常强壮的人。我想他单手就把我拎了起来，而我一直在继续拍摄。他单手就把我拎起来，我说：“哦，我摔倒了吗？”然后我继续拍那个场景。我想我摔倒了。而兰德尔，那是留在正片里的镜头。是的，我们使用了你摔倒然后又站起来的那个镜头。太不可思议了。我记得当时在那儿，用眼角余光看到了这一幕，心想：“我们应该——我们还要继续吗，因为兰德尔在地上？”哦，不，兰德尔站起来了。兰德尔站起来了。好吧，我们要继续。是的。那是克里斯·沃克曼像拎小破布娃娃一样把我拎起来，而且没放开我。我一下子又站回脚上了。不管怎样，我记得的一件事是在《班ihana》那集里，我在“便便滑板车”上摔倒了。我记得我看到的最后一眼是史蒂夫喊着：“不。”总是那样。总是史蒂夫喊着：“不，我接住你。”我想问这个问题。除了在那个场景中救了你的命之外，克里斯·沃克曼过去还经常在片场给你带这种饮料。安吉拉和我都想知道更多。它看起来像是水果和水。这是什么饮料？这是你的特制
shows there's like eight to 10 people just you know, who are looking after two cameras. And on our show, our camera department was four. It was me and Matt and Chris and Ed. And Matt and I pulled our own focus and we pulled our own iris. I would set the look for the cameras, you know, I would program the cameras, what we wanted them to look like and how we wanted them to match. And then the rest of the stuff was just worked out in post, but Matt and I thought it was really important to pull our own focus and pull our own iris. I also think there's again a level of intimacy when the operator is part of the scene and is also listening to the scene. And that's something that doesn't happen
摄像机操作员燃料吗？你看，这就是在泰国炎热的阳光下拍摄海滩上的人与在办公室里拍摄的区别。我在那里可喝不到这种饮料。你知道，那是福利之一。福利之一。我是说，第三季时，我会有的。我喜欢气泡水。是的，我要说的是，我记得当时很忙。是的。我听起来像个如此讲究的人。我喜欢气泡水，我会让克里斯把水果捣碎然后放进我的水里。所以我可以喝到真正水果风味的
on a lot of shows is quite often a lot of shows, the DP doesn't listen to the words. And I wonder how do you know what to do? Yeah. Because coming up in documentaries, I didn't know what to shoot until my sound man put the boom up and said, this is a relevant conversation. You should be shooting this idiot. Don't shoot that. So I still, hey, when I operate, I wear an earpiece. So I'm hearing what's going on so that I can finesse what I'm doing. Now Randall, sometimes on our set, things got a little physical. Who ran into you? Who did you collide with the most? You know, I think I said, I sent myself to the floor in the fire one. I remember that I was backing up through, through the kitchen
气泡水。如果这还不算享受，这不算是成功的标志，我不知道什么才是。我喜欢它。克里斯有一次给我做了一杯，因为我说：“克里斯，你一直给兰德尔带什么？我是那个……”然后他只是狡猾地——把一杯滑到我的桌上。我说，这太提神了。我支持你，兰德尔。我认为这是个绝妙的举动。而且你知道的，你坐在“便便滑板车”上喝着气泡水，一点也不显得太讲究。好吧，兰德尔，我们确实会问我们的嘉宾这个问题：剧集杀青时，你从片场拿走什么东西了吗？我们每个人都拿了一点小东西。你拿了什么吗？
and I fell and I think I hit the ground, but I'm not real sure. But I'm a 200 pound human being and the camera is 38 pounds. And I remember Chris Workman, who's a very strong person. I think he picked me up with one hand and I just kept rolling. He just picked me up with one hand and I'm like, oh, did I fall? And I just kept going with the scene. I think I fell. And Randall, that's the footage that stayed in. Yes, we use the take of you falling and getting back up. It was incredible. I remember being there and seeing it out of the corner of my eye and thinking, should we, are we still going because Randall is on the floor? Oh, no, Randall's up. Randall's up. All right,
我没有。我什么都没拿。什么？兰德尔！我一直期盼着第十季。所以我只是不想破坏那个并确保我没有把事情搞砸。如果我拿了一个我们用过的笔筒，我们就——可能不会回来了。我没有。我没有拿任何东西。我发誓。现在回想起来，如果你当时能拿点什么，你会拿什么？是的，我想大概是写着我名字的牌子吧。我觉得那个挺酷的。我不知道我会拿什么。火灾里的那个烤面包机。
we're going to continue. Yep. That was Chris Workman just lifting me up like a little rag doll and I'm not letting me go. I was just back on my feet. Anyway, one thing I remember is in Benihana, I fell on the putty scooty. I remember the last thing I saw was Steve just going, no. And it was always that. It was always Steve like, no, I got you. I want to ask this question. In addition to saving your life in that scene, Chris Workman also used to bring you this drink on set. And Angela and I need to know more about it. It looked like it was like fruit and water. What was this drink? Was this your special
好了，去吧。很好。好吧，我们应该跟我们的听众分享一下。我想，你知道的，《办公室》女郎的许多粉丝都会知道，兰德尔，你后来成为了一名高产的导演，你正在执导各种精彩的节目。在《办公室》之后，我有幸在《威尔弗雷德》中与你合作。那真的很有趣。那是一个奇怪的小节目。奇怪的小节目，但有一群非常有趣的伙伴。我当时只在那呆了一天，但我很喜欢
camera operator fuel? You see, that's the difference between being out in the hot sun and Thailand and shooting people on a beach and being in the office. I would not get the same type of beverages out there. You know, that was one of the perks. One of the perks. I mean, season three, I would have, I would have them. I like bubbly water. Yes, I was going to say, I remember it was busy. Yeah. I sound like such a fancy man. I like bubbly water and I would have Chris bruise the fruit and put it in the, in my water for me. And so I would have real fruit flavored
那个片场的氛围。但你——正如孩子们所说的那样，你在外面大放异彩。兰德尔，你有什么即将推出的项目或者我们可以分享给每个人去关注的内容吗？我没有以前指导得那么频繁了。我有一个全面开发协议。所以我正在为ABC进行开发。开发非常酷。我喜欢开发。所以我们将会期待你推出的项目。我等不及了。兰德尔，你那双闪烁的蓝眼睛看着真让人高兴——两只眼睛。我们通常只能看到其中一只，但两只都太棒了。
bubbly water. Now, if that's not living, that's not a sign of success. I don't know what is. I love it. Chris made me one one time because I was like, Chris, where do you keep bringing Randall? I'm the one. And then he just sort of slyly, like slid one on my desk. I was like, it was so refreshing. I stand by it, Randall. I think it's a great move. And you know, you're not, you're not too fancy on your poody, scooty with your bubbly water. Yeah. Okay, Randall, we do ask our guest this, did you take anything from the set when the show wrapped when you were done? We all took a little something. Did you take something?
是的，兰德尔。非常感谢你花时间与我们进行深度剖析。我一直非常期待这个。同时也谢谢你允许我们发邮件给你，以及当你接听我的电话告诉我幕后花絮时。你让我的这个播客变得更好了。所以谢谢你。谢谢。这是一段非常特殊的时光。能够重温它，只要有机会我都会去做。所以继续打电话吧。好的，我们会。我正要说，珍娜，我们还没打完电话呢。你感谢他是挺好的，但我们在接下来的——我不知道多少集，还要两年时间里——有更多的问题要问你。有一件事我很想说。我记得当我第一次开始涉足导演工作时，格雷格·丹尼尔斯绝对是我如何开始导演的契机。当我们正在拍摄《办公室》时，格雷格来找我。他说：“你在用摄像机讲笑话。”谢谢。是的，我正在努力。我正试着这么做。他说：“你应该执导一些。”我说：“听起来很酷。是的，我很乐意。”格雷格给了我开始执导的机会。我记得演员阵容里的每个人都非常支持。每个人都希望看到我成功。这意味着很多。这
I didn't. I didn't take anything. What? Randall! I was always hoping for a season 10. So I just didn't want to preserve that and make sure that I didn't screw it up. And if I took a pencil holder that we, you know, we wouldn't come back. I didn't. I didn't take anything. I swear. In hindsight now, if you could have taken something, what would you have taken? Yeah, I suppose my plaque with my name on it. I think that was pretty cool. I don't know what I would take. Toaster oven from the fire.
意味着感受到如此多的支持并让每个人都确保我取得成功，这意味着很多。而且与我合作。这非常、非常特别。然后我记得当我开始想在其他地方做更多导演工作时，我想我做的第一件事是《费城永远艳阳高照》。我记得，哇，我要问问格雷格我是否可以去导演另一个节目。我记得格雷格的回答是：“当然可以。是的，那太棒了。完全可以去。你绝对应该去导演其他一些节目。当你回来时，我们会在这里——我们会敞开双臂，尽管去导演其他节目，只要你还能回来，就回到我们身边。”谁会这样做？好莱坞没有人会这样做。好莱坞没有人会
Yeah. There you go. Nice. Well, we should share it with our listeners. And I think, you know, a lot of office ladies fans will know this, that Randall, you went on and now are a prolific director and you're directing all kinds of amazing shows. And I got to work with you post office on Wilfred. That was really fun. That's a weird little show. Weird little show, but such a fun group of people. I was just there one day, but I loved
这样做。格雷格怎么样？是的，格雷格总是非常、非常、非常高兴我们能开拓视野。作为艺术家，他非常鼓励我们所有人去达成下一个新的里程碑。你说得对。就像你不会——你不会经常发现这一点。你知道的，他也非常慷慨。而且你知道的，甚至到现在，当珍娜和我要做这个播客时，你知道的，我们当时想：“天哪，你知道的，我们不是《办公室》的专家。我们不是。我们只是两个通过制作这部精彩、绝妙的剧集而成为最好朋友的姑娘。”而他的反应是：“我喜欢它。”他非常支持。是的。是的，他说：“问我任何问题。你想让我发照片给你吗？我有试播集的照片。”是的。我们当时想：“是的，他对我们的办公室家族非常关爱和支持，无论我们在做什么。他会看的。他会告诉你他对它的想法。他会为你解答问题。”这是很特别的。这真的很特别。我们所有人都让它变得特别。但格雷格绝对——他以其包容的态度树立了一个非常、非常好的榜样。对格雷格来说，任何人的想法都是有价值的。他是个好人。你是个好人，老兄。你真的是。而且兰德尔，我们绝对会请你回来的。我们想让你来剖析你执导的其中一集。我很乐意。听起来很有趣。哦，太好了。好吧，兰德尔，保重。很高兴和你们一起聊天。谢谢。好的。拜拜。哦，天哪，安吉拉。通过Zoom见到兰德尔太棒了。伙计们，我们会把那张照片发在Office Ladies Pod上，这样你们就能看到我们刚才谈论的蓝眼睛了。是的。就像兰德尔总是拥有的那种酷炫氛围。哦，是的。兰德尔，谢谢你。那太棒了。好吧，那么，女郎们，让我们开始剖析第三季的后半部分，从
the vibe on that set. But you are, you are just out there crushing it as the kids say. Randall, do you have any upcoming projects or anything we can share with everyone to check out? I don't direct as much as I used to. I have an overall development deal. So I'm developing for ABC. Development is very cool. I love development. So we will be looking for your projects coming out. And I can't wait. Randall, your sparkly blue eye is a delight to see both of them. We normally saw one of them, but both of them are wonderful to see.
度假归来开始。我们有一些关于垃圾肉（spam）的新闻。是的，确实如此。大家可能还记得，垃圾肉在这集中占据了很重的戏份。迈克尔在仓库举办了一场派对，他告诉派对筹备委员会他想要一头猪，但他们能找到的只有垃圾肉。我们在剖析这集时有很多关于垃圾肉的问题。谢天谢地，我们收到了很多邮件。是的。安吉拉。是的。你知道垃圾肉是夏威夷广受欢迎的食物吗？根据克里斯滕·奥尔多迪和维奥拉·李的说法。我是知道的。但是，是的，女郎们。安德里亚·理查森写信说，垃圾肉是在二战期间被引入夏威夷、关岛和其他太平洋岛屿的，因为士兵们收到它来代替新鲜肉类。从那时起，它就成为了
Yes, Randall. Thank you so much for taking this time to deep dive with us. I've been so looking forward to this. And thank you too for letting us email you and for when you've hopped on the phone with me to tell me tidbits behind the scenes. You've helped me this podcast even better. So thank you. Thank you. It's been, it was a really special time. And to get to relive it, I'll do that any chance I get. So keep calling. Well, we will. I was about to say, Jenna, we're not done calling him. It's nice that you're thanking him, but we have a lot more to ask you over these next, I don't know how
夏威夷饮食的主食。她说，有一次，甚至还出现了广泛囤积垃圾肉和卫生纸的情况，因为担心战争结束时货运会停止。囤积卫生纸。这听起来很熟悉。触发警报。是的。这也许是最大的新闻，安吉拉。佩吉·S和埃米利·柴尔德说，在明尼苏达州奥斯汀黑斯廷斯有一个垃圾肉博物馆。我知道那个。你想知道我是怎么知道的吗？你知道明尼苏达州有一个垃圾肉博物馆？是的。你怎么知道的？好吧，这太棒了。听听这个。我们收到了来自明尼苏达州奥斯汀的两姐妹发来的最可爱的信。我想向劳拉和阿曼达致以谢意，她们说奥斯汀是垃圾肉的发源地。
many episodes, two more years. There's one thing I'd love to say. I remember when I first started getting into directing, Greg Daniels is absolutely how I got into directing. Greg came to me when we were shooting the office. He says, you're telling jokes with the cameras. Thank you. Yes, I am. I'm trying to. He says, you should direct some. Like, that sounds cool. Yeah, I'd love to. And Greg gave me the opportunity to start directing. And I remember that the cast was everybody was so supportive. Everybody wanted to see me succeed. And that meant a lot. That
事实上，该镇的绰号是“美国垃圾肉小镇”。她们写了这段话，我引用一下：“本着播客的精神，让我们从几个快速事实开始。”这些女孩多可爱啊。我太喜欢了。她们要给我们提供一些快速事实。我要把它读出来。准备好了吗？是的。快速事实一：在加工垃圾肉的日子里，镇上的每个人都会伴随着工厂飘来的培根香味醒来。哦，天哪。迈克尔会喜欢那个的。如果迈克尔住在明尼苏达州奥斯汀，他就永远不会把脚烫在乔治·福尔曼烤架上了。我知道。迈克尔当时应该搬到那里去，而不是去科罗拉多。快速事实二：除了挥之不去的培根香味，垃圾肉在我们生活中扮演着角色
meant a lot to feel so supported and have everybody ensuring that I succeeded. And we're in collaborating with me. And that was very, very special. And then I remember when I wanted to start to do more directing elsewhere, I think the first thing I did was it's always sunny in Philadelphia. And I remember, wow, I'm going to ask Greg if I can go direct another show. And I remember Greg's response was, absolutely. Yeah, that's fantastic. He's totally go do that. You should definitely go direct some other shows. And when you come back, we'll be here, we'll be here. We'll open arms, just go direct other shows and come back to us when you can. And who does that? Nobody does that in Hollywood. Nobody does
这种被全力支持、每个人都确保我能成功并与我合作的感觉，意义重大。那真的非常、非常特别。后来我记得当我开始想在别处尝试更多导演工作时，我想我做的第一件事就是《费城永远阳光灿烂》。我记得，哇，我要去问格里格我能不能去导演另一部剧。我记得格里格的回答是，完全可以。是的，太棒了。他完全赞成去。你绝对应该去导演其他一些剧。等你回来的时候，我们都会在这里，我们都在。双臂敞开，尽管去导演其他剧，有空就回我们这里来。谁会这么做？好莱坞没人会这么做。没有人
that in Hollywood. How's Greg? Yeah, Greg was always very, very, very excited for us to broaden our horizons. And he was so encouraging of us all as artists to meet that next new milestone. And you're right. Like you don't, you don't find that a lot. You know, he's also so generous. And you know, even still, when Jenna and I were going to do this podcast, you know, we were like, gosh, you know, we're not the experts on the office. We're not. We're just two gals who became best friends doing this fantastic, amazing show. And he was like, I love it. Like he was so supportive. Yeah. Yeah, he was like, ask me any questions. You want me to send
在好莱坞这么做。格里格最近怎么样？是的，格里格总是非常、非常、非常兴奋地看到我们开阔眼界。他作为艺术家对我们所有人都非常鼓励，支持我们迎接下一个新的里程碑。你说得对。就像你不会，你不会经常发现这一点。你知道，他也非常慷慨。而且你知道，即便到现在，当珍娜和我打算做这个播客时，你知道，我们当时想，天哪，你知道的，我们并不是《办公室》的专家。我们不是。我们只是两个因为做这部奇妙、了不起的剧而成为最好朋友的姑娘。而他却说，我喜欢。他简直太支持了。对。是的，他就像是，问我任何问题。你想让我发
you pictures? I've got pictures from the pilot. Yeah. We were like, yeah, he's so caring and supportive of our office family, whatever it is we're doing. He's going to watch it. He'll tell you his thoughts on it. He'll answer questions for you. And it is special. It is really special. We all made it special. But Greg was absolutely, he was set in a very, very fine example by his inclusive attitude. Anybody's idea was worth it for Greg. He's a good guy. You're a good guy, buddy. You are. And Randall, we definitely will have you back. We want you to come break down one of the
给你照片吗？我有试播集的照片。是的。我们当时就想，是的，他对我们的办公室大家庭非常关心和支持，无论我们在做什么。他都会看。他会告诉你他对它的想法。他会为你回答问题。这很特别。这真的很特别。我们所有人都让它变得很特别。但格里格绝对是，他用自己包容的态度树立了一个非常、非常好的榜样。对格里格来说，任何人的想法都是有价值的。他是个好人。你是个好人，老兄。你真的是。而兰德尔，我们绝对会请你回来的。我们想让你来剖析一下你
episodes that you directed. I'd love to. That sounds fun. Oh, good. All right, Randall, take care. Nice to hang out with you all. Thank you. All right. I'll bye. Oh, my gosh, Angela. So great getting to see Randall over Zoom. And guys, we'll post a picture of that on Office Ladies Pod so you can see the blue eyes we spoke so much about. Yes. And just like the cool vibe Randall always has. Oh, yeah. Randall, thank you. That was fantastic. All right. Well, lady, let's get started breaking down the second half of season three, starting
导演过的其中一集。我很乐意。听起来很有趣。哦，太好了。好了，兰德尔，保重。很高兴和你们大家一起聊天。谢谢。好的。再见。哦，天哪，安吉拉。能在Zoom上见到兰德尔真是太棒了。伙计们，我们会在Office Ladies Pod上发布一张照片，这样你们就能看到我们赞不绝口的那双蓝眼睛了。是的。就像兰德尔总是自带的那种酷帅氛围。哦，是的。兰德尔，谢谢你。太棒了。好了，女士们，让我们开始剖析第三季的后半部分，从
with back from vacation. We've got some spam news. Yes, we do. You guys might remember that spam featured very heavily in this episode. Michael throws a party in the warehouse and he tells the party planning committee he wants a pig, but all they can find is spam. And we had a lot of questions about spam as we were breaking down this episode. And thankfully, we got a lot of mail. Yeah. Angela. Yes. Did you know that spam is a popular food in Hawaii? According to Kristen Ordodi and Viola Lee. I did know that. But yes, ladies. Andrea Richardson wrote in to say that spam was introduced to Hawaii, Guam, and the other Pacific Islands during World War Two because soldiers received it to eat in place of fresh meat. And it has
《度假归来》开始。我们有一些关于罐头肉（Spam）的消息。是的，确实如此。大家可能还记得，Spam在这集里占了很大比重。迈克尔在仓库里办了一个派对，他告诉派对策划委员会他想要一头猪，但他们能找到的只有Spam。当我们在剖析这一集时，我们对Spam有很多疑问。谢天谢地，我们收到了很多信件。是的。安吉拉。是的。你知道Spam是夏威夷很受欢迎的食物吗？根据克里斯汀·奥尔多迪和维奥拉·李的说法。我是知道的。但是，女士们。安德里亚·理查森写信说，Spam是在二战期间被引入夏威夷、关岛和其他太平洋岛屿的，因为士兵们收到它是为了代替新鲜肉类食用。从那以后，它一直
been a staple of the Hawaiian diet ever since. She said that at one point, there was even a widespread hoarding of spam and toilet paper for fear that shipments would stop when the war ended. Toilet paper hoarding. That sounds familiar. Trigger warning. Yes. And this is maybe the biggest news, Angela. Peggy S. and Emily Childs said there is a spam museum in Austin Hastings, Minnesota. I know that. You want to know how I know? You know there's a spam museum in Minnesota? Yes. How do you know? Okay, this is awesome. Listen to this. We got the loveliest letter from two sisters who are from Austin, Minnesota. I want to give a shout out to Laura and Amanda instead, who said that Austin is the birthplace of spam.
是夏威夷饮食中的主食。她说，有一次，甚至还出现了广泛抢购Spam和卫生纸的现象，因为担心战争结束时货运会中断。抢购卫生纸。听起来很熟悉。触发警报。是的。这也许是最大的新闻，安吉拉。佩吉·S和艾米丽·蔡尔兹说，在明尼苏达州奥斯汀黑斯廷斯有一个Spam博物馆。我知道。你想知道我是怎么知道的吗？你知道明尼苏达州有一个Spam博物馆吗？是的。你怎么知道的？好吧，这太棒了。听这个。我们收到了来自明尼苏达州奥斯汀的两姐妹写的一封最可爱的信。我要向劳拉和阿曼达大声致谢，她们说奥斯汀是Spam的发源地。
And in fact, the town is nicknamed Spam Town, USA. They wrote this and I quote, in the spirit of the podcast, let's start with a couple of fast facts. How cute are these girls? I love it. They're going to give us some fast facts. I'm going to read them off. Ready? Yes. Fast fact number one, on the days when spam is being processed, everyone in town wakes up to the smell of bacon wafting over from the factory. Oh my gosh. Michael would love that. Michael would have never burnt his foot on a George Foreman grill if he just lived in Austin, Minnesota. I know. Michael should have moved there instead of Colorado. Fast fact number two, apart from the lingering scent of bacon, spam plays a role in our lives
事实上，这个镇被昵称为美国Spam小镇。她们写道，我引用一下，本着播客的精神，让我们从几个快讯开始。这些女孩多可爱啊。我太喜欢了。她们要给我们提供一些快讯。我要把它们读出来。准备好了吗？是的。快讯一，在加工Spam的日子里，镇上的每个人醒来都能闻到从工厂飘来的阵阵培根香味。哦，天哪。迈克尔一定会喜欢那样的。如果迈克尔只是住在明尼苏达州的奥斯汀，他就永远不会在乔治·福尔曼烤架上烫伤他的脚了。我知道。迈克尔本应该搬到那里而不是科罗拉多。快讯二，除了挥之不去的培根香味，Spam在我们的生活中扮演着重要的角色
in other ways like our yearly spam jam festival and the creative ways local restaurants incorporate spam into their menus. I am going to a spam jam festival. You are going. We are going. We are adding this spam museum to our list. Yes, but we have to go to the festival. Well, yeah, we got to go for spam jam and then go tour the museum. I love it. Fast fact number three, 90% of spam in 1941 went to the war effort. Our dad always tells anyone who will listen that quote, we would have made it through the war without spam. Those are amazing spam. Fast facts. Laura, Amanda, thank you. Applause. Applause. And I want you guys to know Laura and Amanda sent me spam socks. Okay. They have like a little spam. I love them. I've already
在其他方面，比如我们每年的午餐肉狂欢节，以及当地餐厅将午餐肉融入菜单的各种创意方式。我要去午餐肉狂欢节。你要去。我们要去。我们要把这个午餐肉博物馆加入我们的名单。是的，但我们必须去那个节日。嗯，对，我们得去参加午餐肉狂欢节，然后去参观博物馆。我太喜欢了。速成事实之三，1941年90%的午餐肉都用于战争努力。我爸总是对任何愿意听的人说，引述，“我们没有午餐肉也能度过战争。”这些都是惊人的午餐肉。速成事实。劳拉，阿曼达，谢谢你们。掌声。掌声。而且我想让你们知道，劳拉和阿曼达送了我午餐肉袜子。好吧。它们上面有个小午餐肉。我太喜欢了。我已经
worn them. They sent you a spam hat. So I've got to bring it over to you. And they sent us a photo at the spam museum. We're going to put it in Office Ladies Pod Insta stories. All right. Here's our list. Are you ready? Okay. SAS shoe factory tour. Got it. Hers chip factory tour. Mmm. That watermark paper factory in Italy. Yes. Spam museum. Oh, and yacht factory. And should we go fishing with a bass master? 100% get me a zero puppy on the line. Let's do it. All right. I don't even know what that is. I just remember that guy I dated in college had a zero puppy or something when he went fishing, I think. What's a zero puppy? I don't know. I think it was a hook that looked like a little fish that flopped around. Here's
穿过了。他们送了你一顶午餐肉帽子。所以我得把它拿给你。他们还发给我们一张在午餐肉博物馆的照片。我们要把它放到办公室女郎播客的Ins快拍里。好啦。这是我们的清单。准备好了吗？好吧。SAS鞋厂参观。收到。赫尔斯薯片厂参观。嗯。意大利的那个水印造纸厂。是的。午餐肉博物馆。哦，还有游艇厂。我们应该和鲈鱼大师去钓鱼吗？100%给我钓上一条零号小狗。我们去吧。好吧。我甚至不知道那是什么。我只记得我在大学里约会过的那个家伙去钓鱼时带了一只零号小狗什么的，我想。什么是零号小狗？我不知道。我想那是一个看起来像个会扑腾的小鱼的鱼钩。下面是
what I hear when you say that. I hear zero puppy. Zero puppy. Give me a zero puppy. I don't know. I have no idea. Well, I don't know who's in charge of these kinds of things, but somewhere out there, someone would want to like finance our factory tour. Nat Geo. Nat Geo. Nat Geo. Call us. Jenna, we could do a whole factories around the world with Jenna and Angela. Call us. We're in. We do it. Somebody must know someone there. Tell them. I would watch that show. Okay, lady. I think now you have some background catches for this episode. I do. I'm going to hit you up with them. All right. Christine Bird said at 12 minutes, 11 seconds. Is Michael sitting in his office holding a bottle of chocolate
我听到你这么说时的反应。我听到的是零号小狗。零号小狗。给我一只零号小狗。我不知道。我完全不知道。好吧，我不知道是谁负责这类事情，但在某个地方，会有人想要资助我们的工厂参观。国家地理。国家地理。国家地理。给我们打电话。珍娜，我们可以和珍娜与安吉拉一起做一个全世界的工厂系列节目。给我们打电话。我们加入。我们做。总得有人认识那里的某个人。告诉他们。我会看那个节目的。好吧，女士。我想现在你为这一集准备了一些背景捉迷藏。我有。我要把它们抛给你。好啦。克里斯蒂娜·伯德在12分11秒时说。迈克尔是坐在他的办公室里拿着一瓶巧克力
sauce? Yes. Great catch. I went back to this episode. I went right to that time code. It looks like a bottle of Hershey's chocolate sauce. Like he's got it turned around so you don't see the label. He's holding that in one hand, but then if you look, there is the cap of it on his desk. Was he going to take a big swig out of it, but then Dwight interrupted him like, oh, that's good. I screen grabbed it. I'll put it in stories. Well, Rebecca Lee has a palm tree sighting at five minutes, four seconds when the group is all out in the parking lot and Samantha Tucker saw a palm tree at seven minutes, 21 seconds. Melissa C wrote in to say that she is obsessed with looking for palm trees now because you guys
酱吗？是的。棒极了的发现。我回看了这一集。我直接跳到了那个时间码。看起来像是一瓶好时巧克力酱。就像他把它转过来让你看不到标签一样。他一只手拿着它，但如果你看，他的桌子上放着它的瓶盖。他是打算大口喝一口，然后 Dwight 打断了他，就像，哦，这很好。我截了屏。我会把它放到快拍里。嗯，丽贝卡·李在5分4秒时发现了一棵棕榈树，当时大家都在停车场里，萨曼莎·塔克在7分21秒时也看到了一棵棕榈树。梅丽莎·C写信来说，她现在沉迷于寻找棕榈树，因为你们
remember we did not shoot this show in Scranton. We shot it in Southern California. Yeah. And we tried to remove all our palm trees using CGI in post, but we did not always get them. So Melissa C would like to propose a new element to our rewatch called palm tree spotter. Oh, Melissa, I like it. I want to give a shout out to the underscore photographer. They shared some great details with us about the steel drum that Michael is playing when he sings feeling hot, hot, hot. They said it's actually called a steel pan and is the national instrument of Trinidad and Tobago steel pan musicians are called panace and it's widely regarded as the only major musical instrument to be invented in the 20th century. Wow. Good. Fast
还记得我们并不是在斯克兰顿拍这部剧的。我们是在南加州拍的。是的。我们试图在后期用CGI抹掉所有的棕榈树，但我们并没有全部抹掉。所以梅丽莎·C想为我们的重看节目提议一个新元素，叫做棕榈树搜寻员。哦，梅丽莎，我喜欢。我要向这位下划线摄影师致敬，他们和我们分享了一些关于迈克尔在唱《感觉火热，火热，火热》时弹奏的钢鼓的极好细节。他们说它实际上被称为钢盘，是特立尼达和多巴哥的国乐器，钢盘音乐家被称为盘手，它被广泛认为是在20世纪发明的唯一主要乐器。哇。好。快
back there. I like that. All right. Well, moving on to traveling salesmen. Lady, we got a lot of mail about laundry and betrayal. Yes, we did. We went on quite a tangent in this episode. Yeah. Shawna Z said, I have never laughed so hard at a podcast as I did last night driving home when you guys were talking about funeral poses. I spit tea all over my steering wheel and windshield. F you, Larry. I'm so sorry we made you spit out your tea, but I'm glad you enjoyed it. And Angela C said, please make laundry and betrayal into something real. I mean, it would be kind of fun if we wrote a like limited laundry and betrayal series and did it as a podcast. Amazing. We could get all of our friends to
回那里。我喜欢这个。好吧，接下来是旅行推销员。女士们，我们收到了很多关于洗衣和背叛的邮件。是的，确实如此。我们在这一集里扯得有点远。嗯。肖娜·Z说，我从来没有像昨晚开车回家时听到你们谈论葬礼姿势那样在一个播客上笑得那么厉害。我把茶喷了满方向盘和挡风玻璃。去你的，拉里。我很抱歉我们让你把茶喷了出来，但我很高兴你喜欢。安吉拉·C说，请把洗衣和背叛变成现实吧。我是说，如果我们写一个类似有限的洗衣和背叛系列并把它做成播客，那会挺有趣的。太棒了。我们可以让所有的朋友都
like hop on and play roles. It'd be so great. Well, for those of you who haven't heard what we're talking about, the whole Larry and Marjorie bit, you can go to this episode traveling salesman, go to one hour, two minutes and 20 seconds, and you will hear the whole thing. All right. Well, let's move on to the return, which featured an interview with Ed Helms. So wonderful. So wonderful. A lot of people were curious why we didn't ask Ed how he came to be on the office when we did our interview with him. Cause we usually lead with that. Yes. Well, that is because we covered Ed's origin story in the merger. So if any of you missed that and you're wondering, I had interviewed Ed off air for the merger and Angela, you
加入并扮演角色。那太棒了。好吧，对于那些还没听过我们在说什么的人，也就是整个拉里和玛乔丽的段子，你可以去看这一集《旅行推销员》，找到1小时2分20秒，你就会听到整个过程。好吧，让我们继续看《回归》，其中包含对埃德·赫尔姆斯的采访。太棒了。太棒了。很多人很好奇为什么我们在对埃德进行采访时没有问他是如何加入《办公室》的。因为我们通常以这个开头。是的。嗯，那是因为我们在《合并》那一集里报道了埃德的起源故事。所以如果你们任何人错过了那个并且想知道，我在《合并》时下线采访了埃德，而安吉拉，
talked with Rashida because those were the episodes where their characters first appeared. And I told his whole audition story in that episode, the merger. So you can go back and check it out. Here's a fan favorite moment we failed to mention. Several people wrote in about the scene with Ryan and the lemonade. Brianna said, if you ladies revisited season three, I wanted to say the moment in the episode at 16 minutes, 57 seconds, where Ryan draws a till day and an accent on the lemonade. And then his face after was probably my favorite joke of the whole show. Do you remember this Jenna? Okay. So in the return, Oscar is back from his paid vacation that he was given because of Michael's offensive behavior. And Michael
你和拉希达谈过，因为那些是他们的角色首次出现的集数。我在那一集《合并》里讲述了他整个的试镜故事。所以你可以回去看看。这里有一个我们漏掉的粉丝最喜欢的时刻。几个人写信谈到了瑞恩和柠檬水的那个场景。布里安娜说，如果你们女士们重温了第三季，我想说在这一集16分57秒时，瑞恩在柠檬水上画了一个波浪号和一个重音符号的那个时刻。然后他随后的表情可能是整部剧里我最喜欢的笑话。你还记得这个吗，珍娜？好吧。所以在《回归》里，奥斯卡从因为迈克尔的无礼行为而获得的带薪假期中回来了。迈克尔
is going overboard with Oscar being back. He really wants him to feel welcome. So he decides, of course, we have to throw him a party. Michael says he wants it to be, and I'm quoting a celebration of Oscar and Oscar night that he wants it to be Oscar specific and that he wants to celebrate Oscars, Mexicanity. So at 16 minutes, 56 seconds, you see the party planning committee, they're trying to decorate the conference room using Michael's ridiculous instructions. They don't know what to do. Ryan is using a Sharpie and he puts a till day over the end and an accent over the E on the big, like, you know, bottle of lemonade, the soda bottle. Yes. And he looks to camera and he's like, I don't know. And
对奥斯卡的回归表现得有点过头了。他真的很想让他感到受欢迎。所以他决定，当然，我们要为他办个派对。迈克尔说他希望这是一个，我引用一下，对奥斯卡以及奥斯卡之夜的庆祝，他希望这具有奥斯卡的特定性，并且他想要庆祝奥斯卡的墨西哥性。所以在16分56秒时，你看到派对策划委员会，他们正试图按照迈克尔荒谬的指示来装饰会议室。他们不知道该做什么。瑞恩正用马克笔在一个大的，你知道的，柠檬水瓶，那个苏打水瓶上，在结尾处加了一个波浪号，在E上加了一个重音。是的。然后他看着镜头，好像在说，我不知道。然后
he sets it down next to a sign that says Mexican lemonade. I had completely forgotten about that moment. So Brianna, thank you for bringing it up to the top. A lot of people also wrote in to say that they wished we had discussed this Phyllis talking head from this episode. Yes. Which I love and I'm bummed we didn't. This is the episode where Phyllis famously says Dwight has a big personality and I have a big personality and sometimes when two people like that get together, it can be explosive. So good. Our writers were so good at writing our characters. So good. But I'm telling you, I actually texted Phyllis yesterday and just told her everything that comes out of her mouth is just gold. She is my favorite in
他把它放在一个写着“墨西哥柠檬水”的牌子旁边。我完全忘记了那个时刻。所以布里安娜，谢谢你把它提出来。很多人也写信说，他们希望我们讨论一下这一集里菲莉丝的独白。是的。我很喜欢，而且我很遗憾我们没有讨论。这就是那一集，菲莉丝说出了那句名言：德怀特有很强的个性，我也有很强的个性，有时当两个这样的人聚在一起时，可能会产生爆炸性的效果。太棒了。我们的编剧太擅长塑造我们的角色了。太棒了。但我告诉你们，我昨天真的给菲莉丝发了短信，告诉她从她嘴里说出来的一切简直都是金子。她在
this rewatch so far. She's who I gravitate towards. I just love her. We recently watched Inside Out as a family. And Phyllis is the little sad character in the girl's brain. She is so good in that too. She's the heart of that. Yeah. She made me cry in that. That's like a family favorite of ours. All right. Well, in this episode Dwight goes to work at Staples and we had a fan catch from Elvira Lynn 84 that I loved at nine minutes, 23 seconds, the woman in Staples that's talking with Dwight was played by Charlotte Stewart who played Ms. Beetle on Little House and the Prairie. We also heard from Jesse M who said, she noticed this as well. It might be a fun fact that only an older generation can appreciate. Guys,
目前的重看中是我最喜欢的。她是我最倾向于关注的人。我太喜欢她了。我们最近全家一起看了《头脑特工队》。菲莉丝就是女孩大脑里那个有点悲伤的小角色。她在里面也演得太好了。她是那部电影的心脏。是的。她在里面把我弄哭了。那算是我们全家最喜欢的电影之一。好吧，在这集里，德怀特去史泰博上班了，我们收到了来自埃尔维拉·林84的一个我非常喜欢的粉丝捉迷藏，在9分23秒时，史泰博里和德怀特说话的那个女人是由夏洛特·斯图尔特扮演的，她曾在《草原小屋》中扮演比特尔小姐。我们还收到了杰西·M的来信，她说，她也注意到了这一点。这可能是一个只有老一辈人才能欣赏的有趣事实。伙计们，
during this pandemic, my family did a rewatch of Little House on the Prairie. You know, I watched it growing up and my memories of Little House on the Prairie are like the baby got a fever on Christmas Eve and Paul had to go out in the rainstorm and Nellie was always being mean and did it hold up? It does hold up and it's a really weird thing to watch during current times because like this family, they're just on their own in their little farmhouse and the kids have to be friends with each other and it's just the family unit kind of all stuck together inside. Yes. And every once in a while, Paul will venture off to town and he'll bring back some special treat and it's all very exciting. I felt that very relatable.
在大流行期间，我家重温了《草原小屋》。你知道的，我是看着它长大的，我对《草原小屋》的记忆就像是那个婴儿在平安夜发烧了，保尔不得不冒着暴风雨出门，莉莉总是很刻薄，它经得起时间的考验吗？它确实经得起时间的考验，而且在当前时期观看它是一件非常奇怪的事情，因为这个家庭，他们只是孤身一人在他们的小农舍里，孩子们必须彼此成为朋友，这就像是一个家庭单位全都被困在里面。是的。而且每隔一段时间，保尔会冒险去镇上，带回一些特殊的零食，这一切都非常令人兴奋。我觉得这非常有共鸣。
And I have to point out something. Jesse who wrote in her profile says she is, quote, fueled by chocolate and that really made me laugh. Jesse, I feel you. I feel you. I saw that too. Jesse, we're with you. We also got a lot of mail about the Jim and Pam prank on Andy. Now, this scene starts at 13 minutes, 24 seconds. If you want to check it out. Jenna, if you remember, we kind of made fun. You and I have Jim and Pam's lame spy skills, right? Yes. We had said that we thought it was silly that Jim went to all the effort to sneakily steal Andy's cell phone to then just hand it off to Pam, who then moments later, you know, gets up and then her and Jim walk through the bullpen and she hands it back to him.
我得指出一件事。写信来的杰西在她的简介中说她是，引用一下，“靠巧克力驱动的”，这真的让我大笑。杰西，我懂你。我懂你。我也看到了。杰西，我们跟你站在一起。我们还收到了很多关于吉姆和帕姆捉弄安迪的邮件。现在，这个场景从13分24秒开始。如果你想去看看的话。珍娜，如果你还记得，我们有点嘲笑。你和我，吉姆和帕姆拙劣的间谍技能，对吧？是的。我们说过，我们觉得很傻的是，吉姆费尽心思偷偷拿走安迪的手机，然后只是把它交给帕姆，紧接着过了一会儿，你知道的，帕姆站起来，然后她和吉姆穿过办公大厅，她又把手机还给了他。
Right. Why? Well, many people disagreed with us and they had some theories of their own. Well, Anna White said she thinks Jim gives the phone to Pam so that Pam can get Andy's cell phone number off the phone in the first place because how else would Jim know? She thinks Pam probably emails Jim the number so that he can start calling it after he puts it in the ceiling. Well, my one thought is Andy is the type of guy that gave every single person his cell phone number the first day. But that doesn't mean they saved it. That's true. That's true. But I just have this feeling that Andy has texted Jim like, what up, my dog? Big tuna. Want to meet me for a beer? Big tuna. You're going to answer big tuna. Look at this crazy thing I
对吧？为什么？嗯，许多人不同意我们的看法，他们有他们自己的理论。嗯，安娜·怀特说她认为吉姆把手机给帕姆是为了让帕姆能首先从手机上弄到安迪的手机号码，因为吉姆还能怎么知道呢？她认为帕姆可能把号码发邮件给吉姆，这样他在把它放到天花板上之后就可以开始拨打它了。嗯，我的一个想法是，安迪就是那种第一天就把自己的手机号码给每一个人的那种家伙。但这并不意味着他们保存了它。那是真的。那是真的。但我只是有这种感觉，安迪曾给吉姆发短信说，最近怎样，我的好兄弟？大金枪鱼。想跟我一起去喝杯啤酒吗？大金枪鱼。你要回大金枪鱼。看看这个我在网上
saw on the internet. Big tuna. Well, I like these theories, but I think I'm going to stand by my assessment that this was a lot of effort for a prank that could have been simpler. It's never about the prank. They just wanted to spend time together. You're right, right? Okay, let's move on to Ben Franklin. You guys, big Ben Franklin news. We found Jackie DeBotten, Elizabeth the stripper. However, her last name is actually pronounced DeBotten, Jackie DeBotten. But you might remember she is in this episode. She is also in fun run. And then she's going to pop up again in the finale spoiler alert. Yes, Jackie reached out to me on DM. I got her cell phone and we've been texting. She's so sweet. And she sent in some audio clips about what it was like working on the
看到的疯狂东西。大金枪鱼。嗯，我喜欢这些理论，但我认为我还是要坚持我的评价，即为了一个本可以更简单的恶作剧，这付出了太多的努力。这从来都不是关于恶作剧本身。他们只是想在一起花时间。你说得对，对吧？好吧，让我们继续讲《本·富兰克林》。伙计们，关于本·富兰克林的重大新闻。我们找到了杰奎琳·德博坦，也就是脱衣舞娘伊丽莎白。不过，她的姓其实发音是德博坦，杰奎琳·德博坦。但你可能还记得她出现在这一集里。她还出现在《趣味赛跑》里。然后她将在大结局中再次出现，剧透警告。是的，杰奎琳在私信中联系了我。我拿到了她的手机号，我们一直在发短信。她太甜了。她发了一些音频片段，讲述了在
show. Sam, can you play the clip? Hi, office fans. It's Jackie DeBotten, aka Elizabeth, the stripper from the office. Angela, Jenna, thank you so much for having me on your amazing podcast. I feel so honored to be here and talk about my memories from this iconic TV show. One thing I remember so clearly is just how warm and welcoming this entire cast was. You know, as a guest star actress, sometimes you come on and you feel like you're busting into somebody's family dinner. But these guys from the second I got there made me feel like part of the family and so creative and collaborative and nice to me. It was really such a great memory in that perspective. That is so sweet. I know. Well, in this next clip, she talks about what it was like working with
这部剧里工作的感受。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？嗨，办公室的粉丝们。我是杰奎琳·德博坦，也就是《办公室》里的脱衣舞娘伊丽莎白。安吉拉，珍娜，非常感谢邀请我参加你们这个精彩的播客。能来到这里并谈谈我对这部标志性电视剧的记忆，我感到非常荣幸。我清晰记得的一件事是，整个剧组是多么的温暖和热情。你知道的，作为一名客串女演员，有时你来的时候会觉得自己像是闯入了某个人的家庭晚宴。但这些人从我到达的那一秒起就让我觉得我是他们家庭的一部分，而且他们非常有创意、乐于合作并且对我和善。从这个角度来看，这真的是一段非常美好的记忆。太甜了。我知道。嗯，在下一个片段中，她谈到了与
Steve Carell and also a little bit about what it was like shooting those dance scenes in the warehouse. Sam, can you play that clip? He was so sweet and so polite. I would say the day that I had to do the lap dance in the warehouse. I was not that nervous, but I've also played a lot of strippers in my TV career. Ironically, I don't know why because I'm actually an accountant in real life, but that's probably a different story. We had this amazing costume designer put together this business suit that had so much Velcro on it. It was a challenge to get the ripped off at the right time. We had a couple wardrobe malfunctions, but we did finally pull it off. Hold up. Jackie is an accountant in real life? Yes. Jackie is an accountant. She's a working actress and an
史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作的感受，以及在仓库拍摄那些舞蹈场景的感受。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？他太甜了，太有礼貌了。我要说的是，我必须在仓库里跳艳舞的那天。我其实没那么紧张，但在我的电视生涯中我也演过很多脱衣舞娘。具有讽刺意味的是，我不知道为什么，因为我现实生活中其实是一名会计，但那可能是个不同的故事了。我们有这位出色的服装设计师制作了一套有大量魔术贴的商务套装。在合适的时间把它撕下来是一个挑战。我们发生过几次服装故障，但我们最终还是成功了。等等。杰奎琳现实生活中是一名会计？是的。杰奎琳是一名会计。她是一名工作的女演员兼
accountant. Well, I also asked her if she still gets recognized and here's what she had to say. I do. I live in New York City now, half for the last eight years. As New York City is, there's always a ton of people and the stores on the street, and I'll just have someone randomly in the middle of the day or in the restaurant just come up and go, oh my god, you're the stripper from the office, which makes me laugh. But then, of course, I look around and you can see all these other people looking at me, just random strangers, and I feel like they might think that I'm the stripper from the office, like their office or their office building. I have to explain to them that I know it's the stripper from the TV show, the office, but yeah, these fans and these office
会计。嗯，我也问过她是否仍然会被认出来，以下是她所说的话。会的。我住在纽约市，过去八年有一半时间在这。正如纽约市那样，总是有成吨的人和街上的商店，我会在大白天或餐馆里突然有人走过来然后说，哦天哪，你就是《办公室》里的那个脱衣舞娘，这让我大笑。但当然，我随后环顾四周，你可以看到所有这些其他人在看着我，只是随意的陌生人，我觉得他们可能会认为我是他们办公室或他们办公大楼里的脱衣舞娘。我不得不向他们解释说我知道那是电视剧《办公室》里的脱衣舞娘，但是是的，这些粉丝和这些办公室
fans are the most amazing fans. They're so sweet and they always are asking me tons of questions about what it was like to be on the show and what it's like to work with all the amazing, famous people, and I'm just always so complimentary of telling them how nice everybody was to me and that I'll always remember this one. Yeah, I guess that's it, ladies. Hopefully, you guys get to see all again. Wink, wink. Maybe you do that reunion show. Elizabeth could come back and maybe this time she gets her CPA or something. All right. Love you, office fans. Bye. Aw, thank you, Jackie. She was so sweet to send in those clips. Yes, Jackie, thank you. And Jackie texted me and she said,
的粉丝是最棒的粉丝。他们太甜了，总是问我一大堆关于在剧组工作是什么感觉，以及和所有这些了不起的名人一起工作是什么感觉的问题，我总是极力称赞并告诉他们每个人对我都太好了，我永远会记住这一次。是的，我想就是这样了，女士们。希望你们大家能再次见面。眨眼，眨眼。也许你们会做那个重聚秀。伊丽莎白可以回来，也许这一次她拿到了注册会计师资格证什么的。好啦。爱你们，办公室粉丝们。再见。啊，谢谢杰奎琳。她发来这些片段真是太甜了。是的，杰奎琳，谢谢你。杰奎琳给我发短信说，
my niece is going to be so excited since she is the one to tell me to please check your DMs. So I just love that that her niece is bugging her. So thank you to Jackie's niece for telling her to check her DMs so we finally got to connect. And Jackie said you can find her in a fun indie movie called Crappy Mother's Day and she's the lead. She doesn't know when or where it'll end up. They just finished it, but be on the lookout for Crappy Mother's Day. Up next is Phyllis's wedding. Chris DeLuca had a very interesting theory about who broke wind in Phyllis's dressing room. Chris says Phyllis gives a super quick glance right directly at the camera. Was she trying to blame the camera operator and trying to get them to take the blame? This is very interesting.
我的侄女会超级兴奋的，因为是她让我一定要检查你们的私信的。所以我只是很喜欢她的侄女一直在烦她。所以感谢杰奎琳的侄女告诉她去检查私信，这样我们终于可以联系上了。杰奎琳说你可以在一部名为《糟糕的母亲节》的搞笑独立电影中找到她，她是主角。她不知道它什么时候或会在哪里上映。他们刚完成拍摄，但请留意《糟糕的母亲节》。接下来是菲莉丝的婚礼。克里斯·德卢卡有一个非常有趣的理论，关于是谁在菲莉丝的化妆室里放了屁。克里斯说菲莉丝非常迅速地直接瞥了一眼镜头。她是不是想把责任推给摄像师，想让他们背锅？这非常有趣。
I like this theory. I do too. We forgot that there were more people in the room besides just Michael and Phyllis. Yes, maybe a member of the documentary crew is the one who tuted. I think so. I love this idea. Chris, love it. Angela, we spoke a little bit in this episode about that fur handpiece. Lauren Ramirez wrote in to say it is called a muff. KK, P.L. Watson went on to say they originally had a small zippered pouch inside where ladies could keep a handkerchief, lipstick, etc. in place of carrying a purse. Oh, I would like that. Well, dare I say we also needed this because we had no pockets. Perhaps we had to invent a muff. Oh, man. Just give us some pockets and all of our problems will be solved. Give us some dang
我喜欢这个理论。我也喜欢。我们忘了房间里除了迈克尔和菲莉丝之外还有更多人。是的，也许纪录片剧组的一个成员才是那个放屁的人。我想是的。我喜欢这个主意。克里斯，太棒了。安吉拉，我们在这一集里简单谈了一下那个皮毛手筒。劳伦·拉米雷斯写信来说它被称为手筒。KK，P.L.沃森接着说，它们原本里面有一个带拉链的小袋子，女士们可以在里面放手帕、口红等，以此代替携带手提包。哦，我想要那个。嗯，我敢说我们也需要这个，因为我们没有口袋。也许我们不得不发明一个手筒。哦，天哪。只要给我们几个口袋，我们所有的烦恼就都解决了。给我们几个该死的
pockets. All right, Jenna, I think we should take a break. But before we do, I have to correct something I got wrong and revisited. Okay, this is a revisit of a revisited. So during our revisited with Dave Rogers, I mentioned I was in a Clay Walker music video and Nicole, Erica, Brandy, Hannah, April and many more. Let me know. I got the lyrics wrong to Clay Walker song. Now, if you know me, you must know, I can never get a song right. I know like three words of a song. And then I'm going to botch it as sort of my superpower. Like, I will drive you crazy on a road trip because I just always get the lyrics wrong. So here it is, Clay Walker song. If I could make a living out of loving you, not I could make a million out of loving you. Sam, can you play the
口袋吧。好吧，珍娜，我想我们应该休息一下。但在我们这样做之前，我必须纠正一些我弄错了并重新审视的事情。好吧，这是一个重审的重审。所以在我们与戴夫·罗杰斯的重温期间，我提到我曾出演过克莱·沃克的音乐录影带，而妮可、埃里卡、布兰迪、汉娜、阿普丽尔和许多其他人让我知道。我把克莱·沃克歌里的歌词弄错了。现在，如果你了解我，你一定知道，我从来没能把一首歌唱对。我只知道一首歌的大概三个词。然后我要把它搞砸，这算是我的一种超能力。比如，我会在公路旅行中把你逼疯，因为我总是把歌词弄错。所以就是这样，克莱·沃克的歌。如果我能靠爱你的生活赚钱，而不是我能靠爱你赚一百万。萨姆，你能播放这个
clip? To be fair, Angela, if he made a million out of loving you, he would also make a living out of loving you. So maybe he could flip it. You know, he says if he could make a living, he'd make a million. That's true. That's how much money he could make loving you. Well, I went back and watched the music video for this and I found the moment, the blurry moment where I'm in the video and I'm going to put it in our stories. Oh my gosh, I love these early acting jobs because this is reminding me of when I was a background extra for the Jurassic Park ride at Universal Studios. What a gig. Amazing. It was a gig. It really was. I got paid $100 to ride the Jurassic Park water ride. By the way, it's a water
片段吗？公平地说，安吉拉，如果他能靠爱你赚一百万，他也能靠爱你的生活赚钱。所以也许他可以倒过来。你知道，他说如果他能过上生活，他就能赚一百万。那是真的。这就是他爱你所能赚到的钱。嗯，我回去看了这个音乐录影带，我找到了那个时刻，那个我在视频里模糊的时刻，我要把它放进我们的快拍里。哦天哪，我太喜欢这些早期的表演工作了，因为这让我想起了我在环球影城为侏罗纪公园过山车做背景临时演员的时候。多棒的工作啊。太棒了。这确实是一份工作。真的。我拿到100美元去坐侏罗纪公园水上乐园。顺便说一下，这是一个在环球影城持续12小时的
ride at Universal Studios for 12 hours. No. 12 hours. And no. Yeah. Oh yeah. You guys, wait, I have to put some context in this. I have done this ride. It has got such a huge drop. Yep. I've done it with the kids. We have a, we bought the photo, you know, the photo when you do the drop and the kids face, it's like horror. The drop is so much bigger than you can prepare for. And I got completely soaked. I had to go to the gift shop and I had to buy a pair of sweatpants to wear around the rest of the day because I was drenched. Yeah. This was my first acting job when I arrived in Los Angeles. My friend and I both signed up. Oh my God. We were so excited when we got to Universal Studios. As we're walking in, we passed by Arnold Schwarzenegger shooting
水上乐园。不。12小时。没有。是的。哦，天哪。你们，等等，我得在里面加点背景。我坐过这个游乐设施。它有一个超级巨大的落差。是的。我和孩子们一起坐过。我们有一个，我们买了照片，你知道当你经历落差时的那个照片，孩子们的脸就像是恐怖片。落差比你能准备的要大得多。我完全湿透了。我不得不去礼品店买了一条运动裤，在剩下的时间里穿着，因为我湿透了。是的。这是我刚到洛杉矶时的第一份表演工作。我和我的朋友都报名了。哦，天哪。当我们到达环球影城时，我们兴奋极了。当我们走进去时，我们经过了正在摄影棚外拍投篮的阿诺德·施瓦辛格。我们当时想，我们到了。这将是史上最好的一天。呜呼。12小时后。你离开时哭了吗？
baskets outside of a soundstage. We were like, we have arrived. This is going to be the best day ever. Woohoo. 12 hours later. Did you cry as you left? The difference of us walking to the gig and walking from the gig at the end of the day, we were so beaten down. I want to say, at a certain point, they felt like they weren't getting on camera enough water splashing on us to indicate that it was a water ride. No. So the first thing they did was they had guys with buckets of water that they would just throw on us as we scooted by in the little boat. Oh no. But at one point, not even that was enough. They got out what's called a water cannon. No. Yep. Oh my gosh. They shoot cannonballs of water at you. Jenna, can you, I can't believe I
我们走向工作岗位和一天结束时离开工作岗位的区别，我们被折磨得精疲力竭。我想说，在某个特定时刻，他们觉得他们没有拍到足够的镜头，水花溅在我们身上以表明这是一个水上游乐设施。没有。所以他们做的第一件事就是让几个拿着水桶的家伙，当我们在小船上滑过时，直接把水泼在我们身上。哦，不。但有一段时间，甚至那还不够。他们拿出了所谓的水炮。没有。是的。哦，天哪。他们向你发射水炮弹。珍娜，你能，我不敢相信我
didn't just drive back to Missouri after that. This is being an actor. Yeah. 12 hours. I wrote that ride one time and I was like, I'm never doing it again. Well, if you see the commercial, there is a spot where you can pause and for one second, half of me is on screen. So lady, while you were dancing to this Clay Walker music video, I was getting hit by a water cannon. That's showbiz, folks. Oh man. Well, let's take a break and we will come back and we'll start with business school. All right. We are back. We're going to start with business school. This is the episode with Pam's art show and we got mail lady from so many artists after this episode because they really connected with Pam. This is also the episode with the bat in the office
在那之后竟然没有直接开车回密苏里。这就是当演员。是的。12小时。我只坐过那次游乐设施，然后我就想，我再也不做了。好吧，如果你看那个广告，有一个地方你可以暂停，有一秒钟，半个我出现在屏幕上。所以女士，当你在随着这个克莱·沃克的音乐录影带跳舞时，我正在被水炮击中。这就是演艺圈，朋友们。哦，天哪。好吧，我们休息一下，回来后从《商学院》开始。好的。我们回来了。我们要从《商学院》开始。这是帕姆艺术展的那一集，这一集之后，女士，我们收到了来自这么多艺术家的邮件，因为他们真的和帕姆产生了共鸣。这也是办公室里有蝙蝠的那一集
and several people shared with us about having bats in their offices. What? Bats in their offices? Yes. Listen to this one. Kelly Rardon said, rewatching this episode gave me flashbacks of the time I was working alone in my office late at night during a thunderstorm and a bat started swooping at my head. I was on a tight deadline, so I had to dodge the bat for an hour while I tried to continue working. Kelly, did you get a rabies shot? I hope Kelly got a rabies shot. Remember, you can't always feel it when they bite you. I know they're sneaky. And speaking of bats, Kendra Zane said, I can't believe you guys didn't touch on the rabies foreshadowing with Meredith. Kendra, we totally should have great catch. All right, Angela, remember cocktails?
，好几个人跟我们分享了他们在办公室里遇到蝙蝠的经历。什么？他们的办公室里有蝙蝠？是的。听听这个。凯利·拉登说，重看这一集让我想起了我深夜独自在办公室里工作时遭遇雷雨，一只蝙蝠开始扑向我的头顶的经历。我有一个紧迫的截止日期，所以我不得不躲避蝙蝠一个小时，同时试图继续工作。凯利，你打狂犬疫苗了吗？我希望凯利打了狂犬疫苗。记住，当它们咬你时，你并不总能感觉到。我知道它们很狡猾。说到蝙蝠，肯德拉·赞恩说，我真不敢相信你们居然没有提到梅雷迪思狂犬病的伏笔。肯德拉，我们绝对应该提到，好发现。好吧，安吉拉，还记得鸡尾酒会吗？
Yes, I do. Michael goes to the party at David Wallace's house. Do you remember the creepy ghost lady in the background of Michael's talking head? How could I forget? So creepy. A lot of people wrote in to say they think it was someone from the catering staff. Wow. They noted that the woman is wearing the same burgundy top as the other caterers and they think she's chopping something or maybe washing dishes because her shoulders and arms are kind of moving a little bit. You guys really, really gave this a once over. I mean, if you're clocking her shoulder movements, I'm impressed. Well, Mando said the ghost from the talking head is also in the kitchen at six minutes 33 seconds as David's wife puts down Michael's potato salad. And Leslie Heath said
是的，我记得。迈克尔去参加了大卫·华莱士家的派对。你还记得迈克尔独白背景里的那个阴森的鬼魂女士吗？我怎么会忘？太阴森了。很多人写信来说他们认为那是餐饮服务人员中的某个人。哇。他们注意到那个女人穿着和其他餐饮人员一样的勃艮第红上衣，他们认为她在切东西或可能在洗盘子，因为她的肩膀和手臂有点在动。你们真的是把这一集仔仔细细看了一遍。我是说，如果你连她的肩膀运动都在计时，我印象深刻。嗯，曼多说，独白里的那个鬼魂也在6分33秒的厨房里，当时大卫的妻子放下了迈克尔的土豆沙拉。莱斯利·希思说
you can see her walk behind Michael and Jan at 14 minutes three seconds. This is so much more than I ever thought we would know about this ghost woman. I know it's so true. So not a ghost member of catering staff. Okay. I've got a few more catches for you. Charlie said, I'd like to point out that when Jan presents Michael with their love contract, Michael says, I'm going to frame mine. In the later episode, The Deposition, when Jan is attempting to sue Dunder Mifflin, Michael presents the contract as evidence and it's in a black frame. Nice. It's so good, isn't it? And Chris G says, you didn't mention the fact that Jan drove her own car to the party, but then rode home with Michael. What happened to her car? I had wondered about that. I have to say, I wondered, did they have to drive
你可以在14分3秒时看到她走在迈克尔和简的身后。这比我以往任何时候认为我们对这个鬼魂女人了解的都要多。我知道，确实如此。所以不是鬼魂，是餐饮服务人员。好的。我还有几个发现要告诉你们。查理说，我想指出的是，当简向迈克尔出示他们的恋爱合约时，迈克尔说，“我要把它装裱起来。”在后来的剧集《取证》中，当简试图起诉邓德米夫林时，迈克尔把这份合约作为证据呈上，而且它是装在一个黑色相框里的。不错。太棒了，不是吗？克里斯·G说，你没有提到这样一个事实，即简是自己开车去派对的，但后来却是和迈克尔一起坐车回家的。她的车怎么了？我一直在想这件事。我不得不说，我想知道，他们是不是不得不开车
back to David Wallace's house and pick up her car? You know what I think she did? I think she sent Michael in a cab the next day to get her car. I think she drank too much wine and... Oh, well, that's for sure why Michael drove her, but how she retrieved her car, I bet she made Michael go get it. And then I bet Michael made Dwight go get it. Exactly. Exactly. Well, moving on to the negotiation, my pocket soapbox got a lot of mail. In support of my position, one of my favorites came from Melanie Vergara, who said, ladies, I feel so strongly about the symbology of pockets that I refuse to even consider buying a wedding dress without pockets. And I found the wedding dress of my dreams. It has pockets. She's going to wear it this year. I mean, a wedding dress with
回大卫·华莱士家去取她的车？你知道我认为她做了什么吗？我认为她第二天让迈克尔坐出租去取她的车。我想她喝了太多酒，然后……哦，那绝对是迈克尔开车送她的原因，但至于她是怎么拿回她的车的，我敢打赌她让迈克尔去取。然后我敢打赌迈克尔让德怀特去取。完全正确。完全正确。好吧，接下来是《谈判》，我的袖珍肥皂箱收到了很多邮件。为了支持我的立场，我最喜欢的邮件之一来自梅兰妮·维加拉，她说，女士们，我对口袋的象征意义深信不疑，以至于我甚至拒绝考虑买一件没有口袋的婚纱。然后我找到了我梦想中的婚纱。它有口袋。她今年要穿着它。我是说，一件有口袋的婚纱真是太了不起了。是的。嗯，肯尼，她是一位历史学家，写信来给我们纠正了一个错误。肯尼说，
pockets is pretty phenomenal. Yeah. Well, Kenny, who is a historian, wrote in and had a correction for us. Kenny says, women had pockets throughout history until the 1800s when for various complicated and mostly sexist reasons, women lost their pockets. So yes, the lack of pockets is a sexist thing, but the 400 years ago thing is wrong. It's more like 200. Secondly, she says, corsets were not bad for you. In fact, they gave you great back support. The reason corsets hurt people today is because they either haven't broken them in the same way you have to break in a stiff material shoe before they're comfortable or because they are not fitted properly because people today don't realize the absolute importance of a well-fitted corset and that she would personally take a corset over a bra
历史上女性一直都有口袋，直到1800年代，由于各种复杂且主要是性别歧视的原因，女性失去了口袋。所以是的，没有口袋是一件性别歧视的事情，但400年前这种说法是错误的。更像是200年。其次，她说，紧身胸衣对你并没有害处。事实上，它们为你提供了极好的背部支撑。今天紧身胸衣伤害人们的原因是因为他们要么没有把它们穿软，就像你必须在鞋子舒服之前把硬质材料的鞋子穿软一样，要么是因为它们不合身，因为今天的人们没有意识到一件合身的紧身胸衣的绝对重要性，而且她个人任何时候都会选择紧身胸衣而不是胸罩。
any day. Wow. It's a lot of information there. Kenny, I could not love this letter more. Thank you very much. Although I do have to say, having worn many corsets for acting projects over the year, perhaps they were ill-fitted. I'm going to go ahead and take a bra. You're going to take a bra over a corset? I'm going to take a sports bra if I'm being honest. I don't even want any of the underwire if I can avoid it. You're going to go unibob and be fine with it. Here's the thing. When I get dressed in the mornings, I like to get dressed as if I might have to break into a full sprint at some point in the day. Okay? Your panic button is ready. If you need to run, if you need to haul ass. Yeah. I'm dressed for it. If there's an apocalyptic event, I'm ready. Men are
哇。那里有大量的信息。肯尼，我对这封信的喜爱无以言表。非常感谢。尽管我不得不说，多年来为表演项目穿过很多紧身胸衣后，也许它们是不合身的。我要继续选择胸罩。你要选择胸罩而不是紧身胸衣？如果老实说的话，我要选择运动内衣。如果可以避免的话，我甚至不想要任何钢圈。你要变成单胸块，然后觉得这样也行。事情是这样的。当我早晨穿衣服时，我喜欢穿成好像我随时可能在白天爆发全速冲刺的样子。好吧？你的恐慌按钮已经准备好了。如果你需要跑，如果你需要拼命赶路。是的。我就是为此穿的。如果有末日事件，我已经准备好了。男人本来就是
naturally dressed this way. Truly, a man could pretty much break into a sprint pretty easily, right? Well, I want to survive end of times, a possible mugging. I don't know. So no corsets, no spanks, no high heels for me. I need to run to my bag of expired medication, my book bag with my protein bars, my backpack with the solar panel so I can charge my phone. It's full. You know what I have in my emergency backpack? Angela, we live in Southern California, but I have four of those foil blankets that you wrap around yourself like for extreme cold temperature because you don't know. You don't know the weather shift that's going to happen if a meteor hits the earth. This is like that Jake Gyllenhaal movie the day after tomorrow where, you know, all of a sudden,
这样穿的。真的，一个男人基本上可以非常轻松地爆发冲刺，对吧？嗯，我想在世界末日、可能的抢劫中存活下来。我不知道。所以对我来说没有紧身胸衣，没有塑身衣，没有高跟鞋。我需要跑到我的过期药品包里，带着装有能量棒的书包，带着有太阳能电池板的背包以便给手机充电。它是满的。你知道我的应急背包里有什么吗？安吉拉，我们住在南加州，但我有四个那种像锡纸一样的毯子，你可以在极端寒冷的气温下把它裹在自己身上，因为你不知道。如果有一颗陨石撞击地球，你不知道天气会发生什么变化。这就像杰克·吉伦哈尔的那部电影《后天》，你知道的，突然之间，
this like crazy arctic storm freezes all of New York City. Right. I would have a foil blanket for that and I would have comfortable clothing with giant pockets. I would be as ready as possible. You see what I'm saying? I can't wear a corset. I do. No, you can't. You can't wear a corset. Jenna, you know, my theory on all of this is like what they say about a bear attack. You only have to run faster than one other person. Oh my God. I only have to be faster than one other person in the pack and I'll be okay. It's so interesting. They didn't use that quote in the edge. They went with what one man has done another can do, but yours is also very inspiring. Okay. Well, Jenna, it was also during the negotiation that we discussed our love of
这种疯狂的北极风暴冻结了纽约市的所有地方。对。我会为此准备一张锡纸毯，我会穿着有巨大口袋的舒服衣服。我会尽可能做好准备。你明白我的意思吗？我不能穿紧身胸衣。我明白。不，你不能。你不能穿紧身胸衣。珍娜，你知道我对此的所有理论就像他们对熊袭击的看法一样。你只需要跑得比另一个人快就行了。哦，天哪。我只需要在队伍里比另一个人跑得快，我就能没事。太有趣了。他们在片头没有用那句话。他们用了“一个男人能做到的另一个人也能做到”，但你的也很有启发性。好吧，珍娜，也是在《谈判》中，我们讨论了我们对
Keanu Reeves movies. And last week we found out that you have not been watching John Wick. I'm so sorry. Well, I guess there are a few Keanu Reeves slash the office crossover connections. What? Jenna, we are like six degrees separation of Keanu Reeves. We almost know him. What? Ready? Wait, I could blow your mind right now. What? Have you met him? Jenna Fisher, have you met Keanu Reeves? No, but I was at a birthday party with him for a mutual friend, but I never got up the courage to cross the room and introduce myself. And this happened like recently, like before coronavirus. I have no words. Did I forget to tell you that? What is wrong with you? How could you forget to tell me this? We have talked for six months about Keanu Reeves. I know. And you know,
基努·里维斯电影的热爱。上周我们发现你一直没有看《疾速追杀》。我很抱歉。好吧，我想有几个基努·里维斯和《办公室》交叉的联系。什么？珍娜，我们和基努·里维斯只有六度分隔。我们几乎认识他。什么？准备好了吗？等等，我现在就能让你大吃一惊。什么？你见过他吗？珍娜·费舍尔，你见过基努·里维斯吗？没有，但我曾和一个共同的朋友一起参加过他的生日派对，但我从来没有勇气穿过房间去作自我介绍。而且这发生在类似最近的时候，就像冠状病毒爆发之前。我无话可说。我是不是忘了告诉你了？你脑子有什么毛病？你怎么能忘了告诉我这个？我们已经谈了六个月的基努·里维斯了。我知道。而且你知道，
it's really weird because when you told me I had a Keanu Reeves office connection, I got really excited because I think I'd forgotten that I had actually been in the same room with him once. Well, I have one Keanu Reeves story. I guess I haven't shared it with you. I don't know why we don't share with each other about our Keanu Reeves stories. What's happened to us? We used to be best friends. What's going on? In my early 20s, I was performing improv at Iowa West in Hollywood, and I was at a red light crossing the street to go to the theater with Wyatt Snack. Some of you guys might know Wyatt. He is very funny, talented comedian, performer, and we were standing on the street corner and like an SUV pulled up and in the passenger seat was Keanu Reeves. And I was
这真的很奇怪，因为当你告诉我我有一个基努·里维斯办公室的联系人时，我变得非常兴奋，因为我想我可能忘了我实际上曾经和他在同一个房间里过。好吧，我有一个基努·里维斯的故事。我想我没有跟你分享过。我不知道为什么我们不和彼此分享我们的基努·里维斯故事。我们怎么了？我们曾经是最好的朋友。怎么回事？在我20出头的时候，我在好莱坞的西爱荷华州表演即兴喜剧，我和怀特·斯纳克在一个红灯路口过马路去剧院。你们中的一些人可能认识怀特。他是一个非常有趣、有才华的喜剧演员、表演者，我们正站在街角，就像一辆SUV停了下来，副驾驶座上就是基努·里维斯。我是
prime Kinsey 20s tanked up little shorts, right? And Wyatt Snack goes, oh my god, it's Keanu Reeves. And I was like, huh? And he goes, he just checked you out. Kinsey, he just checked you out. I was like, no, Wyatt, if you are making this up, you better not be messing with me. And then the car pulled away. But he was like, no, and Keanu Reeves looks you up and down. I was like, no, I don't know if this is true. No, you make that you make that true. That's true. Now part of my personal history. It's your personal history. And you can hold that forever. Wyatt, thank you. All right. Well, what are the Keanu Reeves office connections? Because I want to know here are crossover connections. Allie Lincoln said, I have a correction. Speed is fantastic. But peak Keanu
巅峰金西20多岁穿着背心和小短裤的女孩，对吧？而怀特·斯纳克说，哦，天哪，那是基努·里维斯。而我当时想，啊？他说，他刚刚把你上下打量了一遍。金西，他刚刚把你上下打量了一遍。我就像，不，怀特，如果你是在瞎编，你最好别拿我开玩笑。然后车开走了。但他就像，不，基努·里维斯把你上下打量了一番。我就像，不，我不知道这是不是真的。不，你把它变成真的。那是真的。现在它是我的个人历史的一部分。这是你的个人历史。你可以永远拥有它。怀特，谢谢你。好吧，那么基努·里维斯办公室的联系人是什么？因为我想知道这里的交叉联系。艾莉·林肯说，我有一个纠正。《生死时速》太棒了。但巅峰基努
Reeves hotness includes David Denman in the replacements. If you don't get the chills when David is Brian scores a touchdown, you're broken. Wait, so David Denman knows Keanu Reeves. Why didn't we talk to David about Keanu Reeves? Why haven't we been explaining this relationship? Exactly. Okay. And a great catch by Drew Knox. They say the movie speed features the amazing Beth Grant, who later appears in a couple of episodes with you all, most notably in the dinner party as Dwight State slash ex baby sitter Melvina. Yes. Yes. Applause. That is fantastic. She is the woman who's very, very nervous about getting off the bus and walking across the little plank. Yes. To the other speeding vehicle with the police. Oh my gosh.
·里维斯的性感包括《替补队员》里的大卫·丹曼。如果你在看到大卫饰演的布莱恩得分时没有感到起鸡皮疙瘩，那你就是坏掉了。等等，所以大卫·丹曼认识基努·里维斯？为什么我们没有和大卫谈论基努·里维斯？为什么我们没有一直在解释这种关系？完全正确。好的，德鲁·诺克斯的一个伟大发现。他们说电影《生死时速》有惊艳的贝丝·格兰特，她后来和你们大家一起出现在好几集里，最引人注目的是在《晚宴》中饰演德怀特的前保姆梅尔维娜。是的。是的。掌声。这太棒了。她就是那个非常非常紧张而不敢下车并走过那个小木板的女人。是的。走向带有警察的另一辆超速车辆。哦，天哪。
That is just really good Keanu office crossover. I'm moving us along to safety training. Angela, you told the story about how your mom gets people's names wrong. Yes. You gave an example of how your mom would call your friend Bart, Mart. She called him Mart. We asked who would ever name their kid Mart. I think you asked that. I did. I did ask that. Let me just throw you under the bus. Well, it's fine because after we recorded that day, I was curious and I googled it and apparently a lot of people in Estonia named their children Mart and two of Estonia's prime ministers have been named Mart. Mart Silamon and Mart Laher. Mart Laher. Mart Laher. He is a prime minister, former prime minister of Estonia. There you go. We also wondered and Angela, we
这真的是一个非常棒的基努·里夫斯办公室联动。我把话题转到安全培训。安杰拉，你讲过一个故事，关于你妈妈总是把别人的名字叫错。是的。你举了一个例子，说你妈妈把你的朋友巴特叫成玛特。她叫他玛特。我们当时问谁会给孩子起名叫玛特。我想是你问的。我是问过。我确实问过。让我先把你推出去当替罪羊吧。好吧，没关系，因为那天录完节目后，我很好奇去谷歌了一下，结果发现爱沙尼亚有很多人给孩子起名叫玛特，而且爱沙尼亚有两位总理都叫玛特。玛特·西拉蒙和玛特·拉尔。玛特·拉尔。玛特·拉尔。他是爱沙尼亚的总理，前总理。你看。我们还纳闷，安杰拉，我们
both wondered why Andy brought his lunch to work on a plate covered in foil. Yes. Many people, including Lee Miller, Shaley Taylor, Hannah Ermey and Megan Bennett said it was the plate of cookies that Andy brought to share with everyone. It was a deleted scene. Yes, it was. You're so right. I should have caught that. Prison Mike added the people who brought their lunch to work on a plate covered in foil were Roy and Pam. Remember when they were eating their way through all of their unused reception meals? Oh, that is right. Yes. I remember that storyline now. All right. We have more to cover and next up is women's appreciation. Oh gosh, we had some interesting mail on this one. Yes. You might remember that in women's appreciation,
两人都纳闷为什么安迪带午饭到公司时是用一张包着铝箔的盘子装着。是的。很多人，包括莉·米勒、谢利·泰勒、汉娜·厄梅和梅根·贝内特都说那是安迪带来跟所有人分享的曲奇饼干盘。那是一个被删掉的片段。是的，确实是。你说得太对了。我本该想到的。监狱迈克补充说，那些用包着铝箔的盘子带午饭到公司的人是罗伊和帕姆。还记得他们当时在吃完所有没用过的前台餐食吗？哦，对的。是的。我现在想起来那个剧情了。好吧。我们还有更多内容要讲，接下来是妇女感恩节。哦天哪，我们收到了一些关于这一集的有趣邮件。是的。你可能还记得在妇女感恩节那一集里，
Phyllis gets flashed in the parking lot and this leads Dwight to setting up a hotline to find the predator and he holds up a flyer in the episode and it has a phone number very clearly printed on it. And when the episode aired, we shared that if you called that number, you heard a voicemail from Dwight. Well, apparently the phone number on that flyer is now, wait for it, a sex hotline. Yes. So I am filing this under, I don't know, what should I file it under? OMG. Sarah wrote in and said, I called the hotline number from this week's episode. It is a sex call line. Oh, the irony. Guess it's no longer to report flashing now. Jenna, what? I called the number two. You did not. I did. I had to know. I had to know.
菲利丝在停车场被人暴露狂袭击了，这导致德怀特设立了一条热线来寻找这个色狼，他在剧集里举起了一张传单，上面非常清晰地印着一个电话号码。当那一集播出时，我们分享过如果你拨打那个号码，你会听到一段来自德怀特的语音留言。好吧，显然那张传单上的电话号码现在变成了，大家注意听，一条色情热线。是的。所以我要把这个归类到，我不知道，我该把它归类到什么下面？天哪。萨拉发信说，我拨打了本周剧集里的热线号码。那是一条色情电话线。哦，这真是讽刺。看来现在已经不是用来举报暴露狂了。珍娜，什么？我也拨了那个号码。你才没有。我真的打了。我必须知道。我必须知道。
Okay. It's the 800 number on the flyer that's on the prop, right? Yes. So, Sam, I want you to call this number. Welcome to America's hottest hotline. Guys, hot ladies are waiting to talk to you. Press one now. Ladies, to talk to interesting and... Wow. Guys, welcome to the hottest hotline. Let me ask you a question. Yeah. That voice is often used when women are being flirtatious and coy. Men, do you like that voice? Does that voice turn you on? Hey, what is up right now? What is up right now is what I want to know. Are you up right now? I mean, is that, is that getting you there? That voice gets you there. Sorry, lady on sex hotline, but I feel like she's putting on like sexy voice. Uh-uh. I think that's how she talks in real life.
好吧。那是传单上的800号码，就在道具上，对吧？是的。所以，萨姆，我希望你拨打这个号码。欢迎来到全美最火热的热线。伙计们，火辣的女士们正等着和你们聊天。现在请按一。女士们，想和有趣的人……哇。伙计们，欢迎来到最火热的热线。让我问你一个问题。是的。这种声音经常被女性在调情和害羞时使用。男人们，你们喜欢这种声音吗？这种声音会让你们有感觉吗？嘿，现在到底怎么了？现在到底怎么了，这是我想知道的。你现在醒着吗？我是说，那是，那是让你有感觉了吗？那种声音能让你有感觉。对不起，色情热线上的女士，但我觉得她是在装出那种性感的的声音。呃-uh。我觉得她现实生活中就是这么说话的。
I think when she goes to the grocery store, she's like, what is your price on avocados this week? Well, I hope she's not talking to the grocery store workers about that because they're all going to get so turned on. Okay. And a lot of people wished we had discussed a certain scene in the food court where Pam and Karen have very different opinions on Michael's relationship with Jan. Sarah Gray, MC, Michelle G, Nicole Clem, Armanda, Yesenia P, Emily Lucille, and Alexis Leary, and many more. All said, when Karen says, sometimes you just have to push through rough patches and Pam says, maybe it sounds like you two are just wrong for each other. And then they share an awkward look. I really wanted to hear you guys break that down. All right. This is a
我觉得当她去杂货店时，她会说，你们这周牛油果的价格是多少？好吧，我希望她没有跟杂货店的员工谈论这个，因为他们全都会变得很有感觉。好的。很多人希望我们讨论美食广场里的某个场景，在那里帕姆和凯伦对迈克尔和简的关系有着非常不同的看法。萨拉·格雷、MC、米歇尔·G、妮可·克莱姆、阿尔曼达、耶塞尼亚·P、艾米丽·露辛尔、亚历克西斯·利里以及更多人。都说，当凯伦说，有时候你只需要咬牙挺过艰难时期，而帕姆说，也许听起来你们两个就是不适合对方。然后他们交换了一个尴尬的眼神。我真的很想听你们剖析一下。好吧。这是一个
missed opportunity because I do have thoughts. Well, I'm sure you probably did. Here's what I find interesting. I think it's really interesting that their advice to Michael seems to be kind of the opposite of how we've seen them in their own relationships. I feel like Pam was always pushing through rough patches, you know, and Karen always felt to me like the example of a more kind of assertive, empowered woman who would say, listen, maybe this just isn't a match. So I found it interesting that their advice to Michael was a little different than how maybe they live their own lives. Yeah. I mean, they're both just speaking where they're at. That's what I thought. Well, it's true. I think Karen has been in a giant rough patch with Jim from the beginning that she keeps
错失的机会，因为我确实有想法。好吧，我确信你大概确实有。我觉得有趣的是这个。我觉得非常有意思的是，他们给迈克尔的建议似乎跟我们在他们自己的感情中所看到的正好相反。我觉得帕姆总是咬牙挺过艰难时期，你知道的，而凯伦在我看来一直是那种更坚定、更有力量的女性的代表，她会说，听听，也许这根本就不是绝配。所以我发现有趣的是，他们给迈克尔的建议跟他们自己真实生活的方式有点不同。是的。我是说，他们只是在结合自己的现状说话。我是这么想的。好吧，确实如此。我觉得凯伦从一开始就和吉姆陷入了一段巨大的艰难时期，她一直在
trying to convince herself that this is a great relationship for her. So I think there's some truth in that. Yeah. And Pam has finally done doing that. You're right. She's living a more authentic life. She can be more honest with herself. And so she's more honest with others. Yeah. I hear that too. In the same episode, Karina and Maggie wrote in and said they were sad that we did not discuss Angela's large colonial dolls talking head. I was too, Jenna. I was bummed. After the fact, I was like, oh my gosh, that's like one of my favorite talking heads. And I can't believe I didn't talk about it. I think we just had so much to cover in this episode that we didn't get to everything. I agree. But this is for Karina and Maggie. Sometimes the clothes
试图说服自己这对她来说是一段美好的关系。所以我觉得这其中包含一些真相。是的。而帕姆终于不再这么做了。你说得对。她正在过一种更真实的生活。她能对自己更诚实。所以她对别人也更诚实。是的。我也这么觉得。在同一集里，卡丽娜和玛吉写信说，她们很遗憾我们没有讨论安杰拉的大型殖民地娃娃的访谈。我也是，珍娜。我很沮丧。事后我想，哦天哪，那简直是我最喜欢的访谈之一。我真不敢相信我没聊到它。我想我们这一集要讲的内容实在太多了，以至于没能涉及所有东西。我同意。但这是给卡丽娜和玛吉的。有时候Gap Kids的衣服
at Gap Kids are just too flashy. So I'm forced to go to the American Girl Store in order clothes for large colonial dolls. I'll have you know, there is no way you could fit into that doll clothing. I mean, you are tiny. Yes. But I feel like I could put that clothing on my cat. It's very tiny. I know. It's so ridiculous. Oh, oh, and I have to point out one thing on a personal note. This is one of the only episodes that I actually wore pantyhose in. I knew I would be cold at this mall. Jenna, this was our mall. We know this mall. I always freeze. It's cold. And I decided to wear pantyhose. You can see them when I'm seated talking to Michael in Victoria's Secrets. Yes. Meanwhile, I've had pantyhose on for three years because I didn't know that you could just refuse
实在是太花哨了。所以我被迫去美少女时代商店给大型殖民地娃娃买衣服。我得告诉你，你绝对塞不进那套娃娃衣服里。我是说，你太娇小了。是的。但我觉得我可以把那套衣服穿在我猫身上。它非常小。我知道。太荒谬了。哦，哦，我个人有一点必须指出来。这是我唯一真正穿了连裤袜的剧集之一。我知道我在这个商场会冷。珍娜，这是我们的商场。我们了解这个商场。我总是冻僵。里面很冷。我决定穿连裤袜。当我坐在维多利亚的秘密店里跟迈克尔说话时，你能看到它们。是的。与此同时，我已经穿了三年连裤袜了，因为我不知道你其实可以拒绝
to wear them. All right. Moving into beach games. This was a very big episode. And we really did try to cover everything. Again, we missed a few things. We got some mail about the scene where the group arrives at Lake Scranton. So the bus has just parked. Everyone's filing off the bus. Fan question from Alyssa Gessel, Joel M. and Jen Sealy. As Michael gets off the bus, he says, watch out for snakes. And he kind of mugs for the camera. Well, this line actually comes from the movie EGA. Let me spell that for you. It's E-E-G-A-H. This movie was featured on Mystery Science Theater 3000. And that line has become a running joke. So these guys want to know, was the line written or improvised? Do we think that Michael liked the movie EGA? Or do we think maybe Michael is a fan
穿它们。好了。进入沙滩运动。这是非常重磅的一集。我们确实努力涵盖了所有内容。不过，我们还是漏掉了一些。我们收到了一些关于大家到达斯克兰顿湖那个场景的邮件。所以巴士刚刚停下。每个人都在排队下巴士。来自阿莉莎·格塞尔、乔尔·M和詹·西利的粉丝提问。当迈克尔下巴士时，他说，当心蛇。而且他对着镜头做了一个鬼脸。好吧，这句台词实际上来自电影《EGA》。我给你拼一下。它是E-E-G-A-H。这部电影曾在《神秘科学剧院3000》中亮相。而那句台词已经成了一个经典的梗。所以这几位想知道，这句台词是写好的还是即兴发挥的？我们觉得迈克尔喜欢电影《EGA》吗？还是我们觉得迈克尔也许是
of Mystery Science Theater 3000? Guys, we asked Jen Salada, writer of this episode, and she said, this was 100% a coincidence. It was not intentional. When Michael says, watch out for snakes getting off the bus, that line was written because she just thought it would be really funny if the first thing Michael says to us as we arrive at the beach is something that would make the beach completely not fun, which would be snakes. Right. She also said that, I guess, there was a real warning to watch out for snakes, the cast and crew. Yes. I wanted to take a second and mention one of my favorite deleted Phyllis talking heads from this episode. They're all talking about if Jim would be a good boss or not, right? Yes, because he's up for this job at corporate, right? That's
《神秘科学剧院3000》的粉丝？伙计们，我们问过这一集的编剧詹·萨拉达，她说，这100%是个巧合。不是刻意为之的。当迈克尔下巴士时说“当心蛇”时，那句台词之所以被写出来，是因为她觉得如果迈克尔到达海滩时对我们说的第一句话是一件会让海滩变得一点也不好玩的事，那会非常搞笑，那就是蛇。没错。她还说，我猜，对于演员和剧组来说，当时确实有一个当心蛇的真实警告。是的。我想花点时间提一下这一集里我最喜欢的被删掉的菲利丝的访谈之一。他们都在讨论吉姆会不会是一个好老板，对吧？是的，因为他在竞争总部的这个职位，对吧？没错。
right. He's up for the job. And Phyllis says in a talking head to camera, I think Jim would be a good boss. Plus he's eye candy. It's okay. Bob Vance knows he's on my list. George Clooney, Leo DiCaprio, Jim, and that British guy who got in trouble with the prostitute. I guess that would be Hugh Grant. Wow. And Bob knows. Bob knows and he's okay with it. Okay. So Meredith hits on Jim to sign her cast. Phyllis has Jim on her list. Yeah. Wow. Phyllis. The ladies are going after your fella. More fan mail lady from Krista K. She says, I believe it was Jenna that equated walking over lava stones to walking on Lego bricks. I wanted you guys to know that doing a Lego walk, which is walking endlessly on Lego bricks, is actually a thing that happens during Lego fan
他在竞争这个职位。菲利丝在镜头前的访谈中说，我觉得吉姆会是个好老板。而且他很养眼。没关系。鲍勃·万斯知道他在我的名单上。乔治·克鲁尼、莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥、吉姆，还有那个跟妓女惹上麻烦的英国佬。我猜那会是休·格兰特。哇。而且鲍勃知道。鲍勃知道，他对此并不介意。好吧。所以梅雷迪思勾引吉姆让她在石膏上签名。菲利丝把吉姆列在她的名单上。是的。哇。菲利丝。女士们都在追求你的小伙子。来自克里斯塔·K的更多粉丝来信。她说，我相信是珍娜把走过火山石比作走在乐高积木上。我想让你们知道，进行乐高步行，也就是无休止地走在乐高积木上，实际上是乐高粉丝
conventions. Krista said she tried it once and failed miserably, but her husband did all right one year. And during last year's Philly Brick Fest, the Guinness World Record was set at 2,737 feet. But listen to this. That record was shattered on November 20, 2020 by someone named LA Beast, who took a video of themselves walking 12,750 feet over a bunch of Lego. And there's a video on YouTube, but she said it's like an hour long. That is crazy. Someone walked on Legos for an hour. All I could think of as a parent was, oh my God, who had to pick up all those stinkin' Legos when it was done. Yeah. That's a lot of Lego pickup. It really is. Moving us along now to the job. Fan catch from Erica Jane. My thought was that maybe this episode is called the job,
大会期间会发生的一件事。克里斯塔说她曾经尝试过一次，结果惨败，但她丈夫有一年做得挺好。在去年的费城乐高节期间，吉尼斯世界纪录被定格在2737英尺。但听这个。那个纪录在2020年11月20日被一个叫LA Beast的人打破了，他录下了自己在一堆乐高积木上走了12750英尺的视频。YouTube上有一个视频，但她说大约有一个小时长。这太疯狂了。有人在乐高上走了一个小时。作为一个家长，我脑子里想的只有，哦天哪，结束后是谁得把所有那些讨厌的乐高积木都捡起来。是的。那得捡好多的乐高。确实如此。现在我们继续讲工作。来自埃卡·简的粉丝发现。我的想法是，也许这一集被称为工作，
not because of all the people who are vying for the corporate job, but because of Jan's boob job. I saw a few people sort of had this idea and it cracked me up. I know. It is a bit of a double entendre. Double entendre. Yeah. This episode also featured a really great interview with Paul Lieberstein. We got a bunch of mail from people saying how much they loved hearing from him. And lady, we also had people write in and say that they love our tangents, our soapboxes, our deep dives because you apologized because I think you felt a little self-conscious when you were sharing about the limelight, the club inside of the Gothic cathedral. Yes. I went on for a long time and then I realized like, oh my gosh, am I talking too much about this? Well, this feeling
不是因为所有那些在竞争总部职位的人，而是因为简的丰胸手术。我看到有几个人也有这种想法，这把我逗乐了。我知道。这有点一语双关。一语双关。是的。这一集还包含了对保罗·利伯斯坦的一次非常棒的采访。我们收到了很多人的来信，说他们有多么喜欢听他分享。而且，女士，我们还有人写信说他们喜欢我们的题外话、我们的高谈阔论、我们的深度剖析，因为你道过歉，我想当你分享关于林荫大道、那个哥特式大教堂内部的俱乐部时，你觉得自己有点不自然。是的。我讲了很长时间，然后我意识到，哦天哪，我是不是说得太多了？好吧，这种
of being self-conscious and trying not to apologize for things you don't need to apologize for really resonated with people. And I am very happy to see that we are all going to work on this together. Yes, we are. Well, guys, that pretty much wraps it up. But before we go, we did get a question for our sound engineer, Sam. Sarah Vakari would like to know, where are you from in Wisconsin? Oh, I am from Watertown, Wisconsin. It's halfway between Madison and Milwaukee. And our mascot was a gozzling. It was a very intimidating baby goose in a sweater. Oh, go baby goose in your little sweater. Angela's doing some candlesticks as she cheers that cheer for your tiny goose. Jazz hands. And speaking of local treasures, I wanted to give a shout out to
感到不自然、尽量不去为不需要道歉的事情道歉的感觉真正引起了大家的共鸣。我很高兴看到我们都将一起努力改进这一点。是的，我们会的。好吧，伙计们，这差不多就要结束了。但在我们离开之前，我们确实收到了一个给我们的音响师萨姆的问题。萨拉·瓦卡里想知道，你是威斯康星州哪里人？哦，我来自威斯康星州的沃特敦。它在麦迪逊和密尔沃基之间。我们的吉祥物是一只小公鹅。那是一只穿着毛衣的、非常吓人的小鹅。哦，为穿着小毛衣的小鹅加油吧。安杰拉一边为你的小鹅欢呼一边做着拉拉队的动作。爵士手势。说到当地的宝藏，我想向
Christie Adventures. She sent us a walking tour guide of Scranton. It's like a whole map. It's amazing. And I've already looked at it a few times. You gave me one and I literally love it. Yeah, we will use that when we go. Well, there you have it, guys. We have revisited the second half of season three. Thank you to Randall Einhorn for talking with us. And thank you to Jackie Debiton for sending in those audio clips. Yes. And thank you to you all for sending in your questions and comments. There were a lot. We tried to get to as many as we could. I know we missed some, guys. I know we did. But, you know, we'll just keep chipping away at them. If you want to send us a question or comments,
克里斯蒂·阿德文切尔斯表示感谢。她给我们寄来了一份斯克兰顿的步行旅游指南。就像一整张地图。太棒了。我已经看了好几次了。你给了我一份，我简直爱不释手。是的，我们去的时候会用那个。好吧，各位，这就是全部了。我们重新回顾了第三季的后半部分。感谢兰德尔·艾因霍恩与我们交谈。感谢杰基·德比顿寄来那些音频片段。是的。也谢谢大家寄来你们的问题和评论。真的有很多。我们尽量回答了尽可能多的问题。我知道我们漏掉了一些，伙计们。我知道我们漏了。但是，你知道的，我们会继续努力攻克它们的。如果你想给我们发送问题或评论，
head over to the Office Ladies Pod Instagram. We check all our comments there. And if you go to our website, officeladies.com, you can find little folders that correspond to each episode. That's where we pull the questions for our regular episodes and for our revisited. Yes. And on Office Ladies Pod, if you could put your question or comment to the episode it pertains to, that way it has a better chance of making it in. Wait. Wait, guys. That sounded like something I would say. Angela, am I rubbing off on you? You just directed people to an organizational technique. I've never been so excited. Oh, gosh. I didn't know that would do it for you like that. I'll throw out some more of my home organization tips. Okay. Please. All right, guys. We will
请前往Office Ladies Pod的Instagram。我们在那里查看所有的评论。如果你访问我们的网站officeladies.com，你可以找到与每一集相对应的文件夹。那就是我们为常规节目和回顾节目挑选问题的地方。是的。在Office Ladies Pod上，如果你能把你的问题或评论发到它所属的那一集下面，这样它被选中的几率就会更高。等等。等等，伙计们。这听起来像我会说的话。安杰拉，我在潜移默化地影响你吗？你刚刚指导大家使用了一种组织技巧。我从来没有这么兴奋过。哦，天哪。我不知道这会让你这么激动。我会再抛出一些我的家居收纳技巧。好吧。请吧。好吧，伙计们，我们
be back next week with a regular episode. Love you. Love you, guys. Take care. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
将于下周带着常规节目回归。爱你们。爱你们，伙计们。保重。感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安杰拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制片。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要无广告版本的《Office Ladies》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用代码Office。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。